Très bien, ben écoutez,
mesdames, messieurs, juste un
petit mot d'introduction parce
que Emmanuel m'a invité à le
faire. On est très heureux avec
les élus symboliens de vous
accueillir euh dans ce cinéma
Confluence, qui retrouve un peu
d'influence d'ailleurs. Ça fait
du bien. Même si on aurait aimé
euh qu'il y ait plus de monde
euh en salle ce soir. En tout
cas, on est très heureux de de
bénéficier de cette conférence
avec monsieur JANCOVICI on a
beaucoup de choses à apprendre,
effectivement, sur les enjeux
de demain, mais qui sont les
enjeux d'aujourd'hui, je pense.
Donc euh je vais laisser la
parole d'abord à Emmanuel, je
crois et en tout cas je vous
souhaite une bonne soirée et
vous remercie encore de de
votre présence ce soir ici dans
cette salle Merci euh, merci
Monsieur le Maire, merci
Nicolas
Maintenir euh, l'augmentation
de la température moyenne de la
planète euh, en dessous de deux
degrés euh, est un impératif
proclamé euh, tel par la
ratification euh, de l'accord
de Paris et qui nous sommes de
passer d'une logique
d'intention et d'ambition à une
logique d'action et d'exécution
que ce soit en matière
d'urbanisme, de biodiversité,
d'industrie, le champ euh,
couvert par la transition
écologique est large et appelle
à une modification de nos
comportements, de nos objectifs
et des que nous menons face aux
conséquences directes de nos
modes de vie, de nos habitudes
de consommation, de notre
rythme de production actuelle,
la question n'est plus de
savoir si nous devons agir mais
bien de définir comment nous
allons agir. Nous devons être à
la hauteur des enjeux, éteindre
à la lumière en sortant d'une
pièce ou trier ses déchets ne
suffiront plus. La réussite de
la transition écologique en
Sarthe sera étroitement
dépendante de la pertinence de
sa déclinaison dans nos
territoires mais aussi de
l'appropriation de cet enjeu de
l'ensemble publique et en
premier lieu par l'ensemble des
élus et JANCOVICI dans cette
logique que le Pays Vallée de
la Sarthe a élaboré son plan
euh, climat en concertation
avec les soixante-deux communes
et les trois communautés de
communes qui le composent. Ce
plan est en effet JANCOVICI qui
a impliqué l'ensemble des
parties prenantes locales,
aussi bien citoyens qu'acteurs
associatifs, dirigeants
d'entreprises ou commerçants.
Il s'est traduit en objectif
concret, réduire nos
consommations énergétiques de
seize pour cent d'ici à
deux-mille-trente, réduire nos
nos émissions de gaz à effet de
serre de plus de quinze pour
cent tout en augmentant nos
capacités de stockage de
carbone de dix-huit pour cent
d'ici deux-mille-trente et en
multipliant par deux virgule
cinq la production locale
d'énergie renouvelable Nous
n'allons pas nous satisfaire
d'actions marginales, de
compensation sans réduction ou
d'annonces non suivies d'action
Ensemble, nous allons repenser
nos modes de déplacement, nos
modes de chauffage, nos
habitudes de consommation et de
travail et plus globalement,
notre rapport à la nature.
Ensemble, nous allons imaginer,
instaurer ou adapter des
solutions qui soient cohérentes
avec nos territoires ruraux et
avec nos spécificités locales.
Les collectivités territoriales
ont des leviers majeurs à leur
disposition au travers des
domaines et des compétences
dont elles se saisissent,
organisation de la voirie,
mobilité, aménagement du
territoire, construction
gestion du patrimoine bâti,
gestion des déchets, JANCOVICI
des emplois à nous d'identifier
les activités à risque, à nous
de valoriser les formations de
nos équipes, à nous d'assurer
hein, l'information éclairée de
nos concitoyens. Tout cela sans
oublier que la transition a
impulsé se mène également par
des actes individuels. De mon
côté, j'ai fait le calcul de
mon empreinte carbone, onze
tonnes, je suis dans la moyenne
française, et pour donner, je
sais, mais pas encore je vais
quand même attendre votre
conférence monsieur mais pour
donner à chacun les moyens
d'atteindre l'ambition des deux
tonnes prônées par l'Accord de
Paris nous allons devoir
proposer des alternatives
sérieuses à chacun de nos
concitoyens sans laisser de
côté l'aspect social, sans
créer d'exclusions ou de
problèmes socio-économiques,
sans oublier que la réussite de
la transition écologique est
indissociable de
l'acceptabilité sociale. Le
chemin sera long et incertain,
mais le défi est palpitant et
pour nos enfants il est vit
littéralement. Agissons donc
toujours avec une ambition
renouvelée. Merci à notre
invité exceptionnel de
Jean-Marc JANCOVICI de nous
faire l'honneur de sa présence
à Sablé-sur-Sarthe ce soir.
Merci à toutes et à tous d'être
présents. Merci également à
celles et ceux qui nous suivent
en direct sur Facebook et merci
à l'équipe technique d'avoir
gérer l'organisation de cette
soirée sous la houlette de
Céline Bielle, la directrice du
Pays Vallée de la Sarthe. Bonne
soirée à tous.
Je mets mes lunettes de mamie
Alors bonsoir à tous. Ben moi
aussi je dis je vous remercie
d'être présents ce soir. On
aurait dû être deux-cents
n'auraient largement rempli la
salle. En effet on a voulu
privilégier la présence des
élus ici ce soir du territoire
du syndicat Pays Vallée de la
Sarthe mais euh on aurait aimé
accueillir plus de personnes en
présentiel d'autant que
certains étaient prêts à venir
d'Angoulême pour assister à
cette conférence Nous avons
donc la chance d'accueillir ce
soir Jean-Marc et JANCOVICI .
Euh pour ceux qui ne le
connaissent pas, Jean-Marc est
ingénieur de l'école
polytechnique, diplômée de
l'École nationale euh
supérieure des
télécommunications, il est le
créateur du bilan carbone qu'il
a développé au sein de l'ADEM.
Il a co-fon en deux-mille-sept
avec Alain Grangean Carbone
quatre, un cabinet de conseil
qui réalise des bilans carbone
pour les entreprises. Euh, j'ai
copié collé euh, Wikipédia, je
me suis pas cassé la tête hein
ainsi que l'association The
Shift Project en deux-mille-dix
qui est un laboratoire d'idées,
qui s'est donné pour objectif
l'atténuation du changement
climatique et la réduction de
la dépendance de l'économie aux
énergies fossiles. Il est
également membre du Haut
Conseil pour le climat et je
vous passe ces autres activités
dont la logistique est longue
comme le bras. J'ai eu de
rencontrer Jean-Marc euh
l'année dernière c'était même
il y a plus il y a plus de ça,
c'était au mois d'octobre
deux-mille-dix-neuf dans le
cadre de la convention
citoyenne du pour le climat,
Jean-Marc était venu faire une
intervention de cinq, six
minutes, c'était pas beaucoup
d'ailleurs, c'était pas assez,
mais bref, après on a bu un
coup ensemble, on a fait
connaissance et euh ensuite
j'ai voulu participer à un
atelier du shift Project, le
shift fait des ateliers, je
crois que c'est tous les mois
hein. Alors depuis le covid ben
c'est en en visioconférence
mais c'est pratique aussi parce
que les ateliers sont à Paris.
Et ben je ne vais pas à Paris
tous tous les mois Les
JANCOVICI inscrite les équipes
du shift ont vu que je faisais
partie de la convention et du
coup euh, ils m'ont repéré, ils
m'ont dit, est-ce que vous
pouvez participer à une table
ronde avec Jean-Marc? Bon,
d'accord. Et s'en est suivi une
euh, une euh, une série
d'interventions donc d'abord en
présentiel en vision conférence
et depuis on a gardé euh, le
lien. Voilà comment aujourd'hui
l'illustre Jean-Marc JANCOVICI
est
aujourd'hui assablé euh, il
nous fait le plaisir et
l'honneur d'être là parce que
c'est pas non plus une contrée
qui qui visite souvent comme tu
nous disais tout à l'heure euh,
tu passes mais tu t'arrêtes pas
euh, voilà euh, c'est tout moi
hein, je passe la parole à à
Céline pour euh, le côté
technique de la soirée, merci à
tous.
Merci, bonsoir à toutes et à
tous euh, bienvenue euh, donc
je m'appelle Céline Biel, je
suis la directrice du Pays
Vallée de la Sarthe donc, au vu
du contexte sanitaire
évidemment on vous demande de
garder vos masques pendant la
durée de toute la conférence et
de respecter les gestes
barrière ça fait un peu hôtesse
de l'air quand je dis ça mais
vraiment c'est important donc
la jauge est limitée ce soir à
trente-cinq pour cent de la
capacité de la salle mais en
même temps que la conférence on
organise une captation vidéo et
une retransmis en direct sur
notre page Facebook voilà comme
ça ça permet à plus de monde de
nous suivre et j'en profite
pour remercier toute l'équipe
technique d'AFGBL Audiovisuel
sans qui tout ça n'aurait pas
été possible. Pendant la
conférence nous aurons aussi
euh, une traduction illustrée
des propos de monsieur
JANCOVICI et là j'en profite
pour remercier Cécile Moline
qui est notre facilitatrice
graphique et qui nous suivra
toute la soirée. Enfin fin de
la présentation on aura un
temps d'échange et de débat
euh, alors pour poser vos
questions on vous invite à nous
envoyer des SMS au numéro de
téléphone qui va peut-être
s'afficher euh, derrière moi ou
pas, donc je vais vous le
donner parce que je l'ai sur ma
note donc c'est au zéro six
soixante-dix-huit quatorze
Voilà ça nous évitera en fait
de faire circuler le micro et
ça permettra à celles et ceux
qui sont en visio euh, bah de
se sentir aussi à l'aise euh,
que nous présents dans la salle
pour poser leurs questions.
Voilà et enfin un dernier mot
pour euh, remercier l'équipe du
cinéma Confluence euh, Hélène
et Anaïs de nous accueillir
euh, ce soir et puis aussi
toutes les petites mains euh,
du pays qu'on à l'organisation
de la soirée. Donc euh Carole,
Isabelle, Laurine, Julie et
Olivier et Marguerite qui est
pas tout à fait de l'équipe
mais qu'elle a quand même. Euh
voilà. Je vous souhaite une
très belle soirée et je vous
demande euh d'accueillir comme
il se doit Jean-Marc JANCOVICI
Moi j'ai droit à un micro
désinfecté, c'est parfait.
du coup j'ai le droit de
l'infecter. Voilà. Je lui ai
retiré ça.
alors avant
de commencer cette
intervention euh, maintenant
que vous savez tout sur le
marié carboniquement au premier
regard entre Mélanie et moi
euh, comme c'est elle qui m'a
invité j'ai mis Souvigné, voilà
je suis désolé euh, les autres
n'existent pas euh, c'est comme
ça. Euh, la deuxième chose euh,
avant de avant de démarrer
c'est que j'espère que le titre
un tout petit peu violent euh,
ne va pas vous rebuter mais en
fait j'aurais aussi pu
intituler cette intervention
euh, JANCOVICI vous verrez
qu'en fait c'est à peu près la
même chose et j'aurais
également pu l'intituler le
drame de l'élu euh, parce que
vous allez comprendre à la fin
de l'intervention que c'est
justement de ça entre autres
euh, dont il est question.
Alors, mais comme j'ai marqué
physique, je vais aller
jusqu'au bout du, vous savez,
il faut boire le calice jusqu'à
la lie, alors je vais aller
jusqu'au bout de la lit et je
vais commencer avec une
horrible équation. Alors, c'est
pas une horrible équation, en
fait, c'est un truc assez
simple. Ce que je vais essayer
de vous expliquer pendant les
euh, les les quelques quarts
d'heure là, pendant lesquels je
vais causer tout seul comme un
grand avant les questions,
c'est que quand on regarde des
deux derniers siècles. En fait,
on peut assez facilement
montrer que il y a eu autant
d'économies que il y a eu
d'énergie et il y a eu autant
de CO2, c'est-à-dire de futurs
changements climatiques qu'il y
a eu d'énergie. Donc en gros,
si vous regardez les deux
derniers siècles, vous vous
rendez compte que il y a trois
choses qui ont évolué de
concerts. C'est la taille de
l'économie euh, la quantité
d'énergie qu'on utilise et les
JANCOVICI de CO2, tout ça est
allé à peu près à la même
vitesse et euh, on va essayer
de comprendre pourquoi. euh, la
première chose que je vais
faire c'est de vous montrer
qu'effectivement je vous
raconte pas de carabistouille
euh, quand je vous dis que
l'économie et l'énergie sont
allés à peu près à la même
vitesse. Alors, voici une
petite courbe que je que j'ai
commencé à faire euh, pour voir
la tête que ça avait il y a une
dizaine d'années puis enfin oui
une quinzaine d'années
maintenant, depuis le temps que
je dis dix ans euh, et quand
j'ai vu la tête que ça avait,
je me suis dit tiens il y a
truc, c'est vraiment très
étonnant, je vais essayer de
comprendre. Alors, ce que ce
que cette courbe elle est très
simple. Vous avez euh, sur ce
graphique en Absis, donc sur
l'axe horizontal, la quantité
qu'on utilise dans le monde,
peu importe l'unité. Et puis
vous avez en ordonné ce qu'on a
coutume d'utiliser pour
quantifier la taille de
l'économie, c'est-à-dire le
PIB. Vous savez le fameux PIB
euh celui qui quand il monte
tout va bien, quand il descend
tout va mal et qui en fait euh
quantifie la taille de
l'économie euh pour ceux
d'entre qui sont pas très
familiers euh de cette notion.
Le PIB c'est juste la valeur
totale de tout ce qu'on a
produit dans l'année. Voilà,
c'est ça le c'est ça le le PIB.
Eh bien vous voyez que la
valeur totale de ce qu'on
produit dans l'année évolue de
manière euh, parfaitement
linéaire en fonction de la
quantité d'énergie qu'on
utilise. Donc en gros, plus il
y a d'énergie, plus il y a de
PIB, plus il y a de PIB, plus
il y a d'énergie. Ça vous dit
toujours pas où est la poule et
We Love. Mais ce que vous
voyez, c'est qu'effectivement,
le premier terme de mon égalité
est respecté, plus il y a
d'énergie et c'est linéaire. Tu
sais, ça augmente exactement de
la même manière. Voilà la
deuxième courbe qui va avec la
deuxième partie de mon
JANCOVICI alors je recommence,
même motif, même punition. En
bas là cette fois-ci vous avez
la quantité totale d'énergie
qu'on utilise dans le monde et
sur l'axe, vous avez la
quantité totale de CO2 qu'on
crache dans l'atmosphère à
cause de l'utilisation de
l'énergie. Eh ben vous voyez
qu'on a affaire à une droite à
nouveau parfaite. Donc plus il
y a d'énergie, plus il y a de
CO2, plus il y a de CO2, plus
il y a d'énergie. Si vous
essayez de trouver dans cette
courbe l'arrivée euh du
nucléaire ou des énergies
renouvelables, vous le voyez
pas. Vous le voyez pas Et ça
reste parfaitement rectiligne.
Euh en bas à gauche là vous
êtes en
mille-neuf-cent-soixante-cinq,
en haut à droite vous êtes en
deux-mille-dix-neuf. Vous
pouvez autant d'énergie qu'il y
a de CO2, autant d'énergie
qu'il y a de ces autant de de
CO2 qu'il y a d'énergie. Alors
maintenant euh je vous ai
montré que les trois termes de
cette JANCOVICI se valaient
vraiment, euh encore une fois
on va essayer de comprendre
pourquoi et pour comprendre
pourquoi euh on va ramener euh
à la vie active un retraité il
y a pas de raison, il a pas
l'âge. Euh et on va essayer de
commencer à répondre à la
question qui est qu'est-ce que
l'énergie? Alors vous savez que
dans ce pays il y a un ministre
de l'énergie. Vous êtes au
courant hein qu'il y a un
ministre de l'énergie et bien
je vous mon billet que euh, si
on lui pose la question de
savoir ce que c'est que
l'énergie, vous allez JANCOVICI
la bonne réponse. Euh, vous
l'avez dit pourquoi? Alors, un
premier réflexe très pavlovien
qui nous vient à l'esprit quand
on nous dit JANCOVICI c'est
c'est ça et du reste on l'a
très bien vu à cette époque-là.
Vous voyez ça euh, très bien
vu, l'énergie c'est une facture
euh, c'est pas un sujet et tu
restes très souvent quand vous
avez des débats euh, sur
l'énergie, c'est des débats sur
la facture d'électricité,
combien ça va coûter, les
débats sur la facture de gaz,
combien ça va coûter? Alors
malheureusement ce que je vais
essayer de vous montrer c'est
que c'est pas la bonne question
euh, parce que quand on regarde
ce que nous coûte l'énergie au
regard des services que ça nous
rend, en fait la seule bonne
réponse sur le coût de
l'énergie c'est que c'est
gratuit. Voilà, c'est à peu
près la seule bonne réponse sur
le coût de l'énergie. Alors, en
fait c'est pas tout à fait
gratuit mais pas loin. Si je
regarde ce que coûte aux hommes
et aux femmes dans le monde,
globalement euh, l'énergie que
nous utilisons, donc le
pétrole, le charbon, le gaz,
l'électricité vous allez voir
que en fait c'est très souvent
du charbon et du gaz. Eh bien,
ça quelques pour cent de ce
qu'on gagne, quelques pour cent
du PIB donc quelques pour cent
de ce qu'on gagne euh, chaque
année donc le le le coût total,
le fait d'acheter du pétrole,
du gaz et du charbon dans le
monde ça coûte quelques pour
cent de ce qu'on gagne. et
alors à ce moment si euh, c'est
comme ça qu'on prend le
problème c'est-à-dire sous
l'angle de combien ça coûte eh
bien, ce qu'on va faire c'est
qu'on va y passer quelques pour
cent du temps au mieux parce
que un problème qui coûte
quelques pour cent de ce qu'on
gagne, on va pas y passer la
nuit, c'est quand même plus
important de s'occuper de son
loyer et quand on dirige une
entreprise c'est plus important
de s'occupe des salaires euh,
et des charges. Voilà. Alors,
malheureusement ce que ce
raisonnement ne vous dit pas
c'est combien tout le reste en
dépend. Parce que vous voyez
votre cervelle c'est deux pour
cent de votre poids C'est juste
deux pour cent de votre poids
donc je pourrais vous dire bah,
c'est pas grave si vous la
perdez, vous allez perdre deux
pour cent d'efficacité pas
grave. Bon. En fait vous
comprenez bien que ce
raisonnement est totalement
JANCOVICI parce que ça a beau
être deux pour cent de votre
poids, tout le reste de votre
corps en dépend, car si je vous
enlève votre cervelle, plus
plus rien du reste ne
fonctionne. Et comme je vois
que cette salle est masculine
euh, je vais vous donner un
autre exemple euh, le poids de
la testostérone dans les
organismes masculins que j'ai
en face de moi c'est beaucoup
moins que deux pour cent de
votre poids et je peux vous
JANCOVICI je vous l'enlève
votre corps ne ressemble plus à
ce qu'il est donc euh, la
question de la part de
Camembert dans les dépenses en
fait masque une information
essentielle c'est combien tout
le reste de ce qu'on fait
dépend de cette part-là? Alors
je vais vous donner un exemple
JANCOVICI un engin de transport
que je viens d'utiliser
aujourd'hui qui s'appelle un
train. Au sein de la SNCF
covid, l'énergie ça leur coûte
à peu près trois pour cent de
leur chiffre d'affaires et il
faut savoir que la SNCF est le
premier consommateur
d'électricité du pays, la SNCF
Or Covid consomme un virgule
cinq pour cent de la production
électrique du pays et c'est
également un des premiers
consommateurs d'hydrocarbures
puisque beaucoup de TER
fonctionnent au diesel euh,
dont vous avez également un
gros poste d'achat
d'hydrocarbures euh, à la SNCF.
Eh bien, tout ça tout mouillé,
c'est trois pour cent. Sauf que
si vous leur enlevez, vous avez
plus un train qui avance. Donc
on on comprend bien que ces
trois pour cent des charges
mais tout le reste en dépend.
C'est pas trois pour cent
équivalent à autre chose. Par
exemple à des salaires de parce
que si vous enlevez trois pour
cent de charge sous forme de
salaire la SNCF la SNCF pardon
se met en grève mais enfin euh,
derrière il y aura quand même
des trains qui finiront pas
rouler. Donc euh, l'énergie
encore une fois si on regarde
que ça vaut dans ce qu'on
dépense, en fait on rate un
point essentiel tout le reste
de ce qu'on fait dépend de
cette part-là Alors après il y
a une deuxième réponse, vous la
connaissez Deuxième réflexe
Pablovien c'est faut
l'économiser. Et du reste vous
connaissez tous cette petite
Maxime? Vous faire répéter tous
en ctous en ctous en
cEuh la meilleure énergie
est celle qu'on ne consomme
pas. Du reste si vous demandez
un moteur de recherche dont je
ne nommerai pas le nom euh si
vous tapez le début la
meilleure énergie, vous
regardez ce qui arrive derrière
c'est celle qu'on consomme pas,
voilà et cetera. Alors ou bien
on est sourd, ou bien nous
sommes bêtes parce que ça fait
un siècle et demi que la
meilleure énergie est celle
qu'on consomme de plus en plus.
Donc il y a probablement
JANCOVICI en cours dans cette
histoire parce que c'est celle
qu'on consomme pas c'est pas du
tout ça qu'on devrait observer.
Ici vous avez la quantité
totale d'énergie qu'on utilise
sur terre depuis un siècle et
demi. Alors ce que vous pouvez
voir c'est que historiquement
tout en bas là en vert on a
commencé par utiliser du bois
puis on a aussi utilisé j'y
JANCOVICI dans pas longtemps
euh, les autres énergies
renouvelables. Et puis
par-dessus le bois on s'est mis
à utiliser du charbon mais
par-dessus vous voyez que ça
remplace pas. Après par-dessus
on s'est mis à utiliser du
pétrole mais ça remplace pas le
charbon Par dessus le pétrole
on s'est mis à utiliser du gaz,
ça remplace rien de ce qu'il y
avait avant. Par-dessus
l'hydroélectricité par dessus
le nucléaire puis alors tout en
haut en rose là ce que vous
voyez c'est les nouvelles
énergies renouvelables. Donc
c'est le machin dont on tartine
les journaux à longueur de
journée et regardez ce que ça
représente aujourd'hui. Comme
part dans l'approvisionnement
énergétique mondial euh vous
voyez que pour le moment euh
c'est quelque chose qui a une
importance qui n'est pas du
tout en en rapport euh avec euh
la la pagination que ça peut
occuper euh dans le journal.
Maintenant vous êtes tous bien
placés puisque un certain
nombre d'entre vous dans cette
salle sont élus. Pour ça que en
première approximation il y a
pas le moindre rapport entre
l'importance réelle de quelque
chose et la place que ça occupe
dans le journal hein et c'est
pas vrai juste pour l'énergie
euh, c'est vrai d'une manière
générale et bah, c'est aussi
vrai pour l'énergie voilà ce
que vous voyez également sur
cette courbe c'est que euh, il
y a un certain nombre
d'évolutions alors euh, en fait
sur cette courbe on peut placer
plein de trucs dont on dit
aujourd'hui ah mais si on fait
ça ça va permettre d'utiliser
moins d'énergie parce que c'est
plus efficace. Alors je vous en
livre quelques-uns pêle-mêle
mais j'aurais pu en prendre
d'autres hein. On a souvent
entendu c'est plus efficace de
rassembler les gens dans les
villes parce que comme ça c'est
plus compact et alors les gens
du coup se déplacent moins et
cetera. Eh bien vous voyez
l'essor des villes, le boom des
dans le monde, ça commence
après-guerre et vous voyez
l'évolution de la consommation
d'énergie derrière,
manifestement ça a pas été si
efficace que ça. Autre chose,
l'économie se tertiarise. Il y
a de plus en plus de services.
Alors s'il y a de plus en plus
de services, c'est de moins en
moins consommateurs d'énergie
et cetera. Regardez l'évolution
derrière, ça doit se discuter.
Euh que ça a permis. Et enfin
un dernier truc euh, c'est la
digitalisation, alors la
digitalisation c'est plus
efficace, ça évite de se
déplacer et cetera, mais
regardez comment évolue la
consommation d'énergie après
qu'on ait commencé à avoir des
ordinateurs, manifestement ça
marche pas si facilement que
ça. Et là-dessus j'aurais pu
vous mettre n'importe quoi
d'autre hein, la conquête de la
Lune, l'invention de la
voiture, l'invention des
trains, enfin vous mettez ce
que vous voulez. Vous voyez
qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a pas la
moindre invention technique. On
dit aujourd'hui que elle va
permettre de régler le
problème. La consommation
croissante d'énergie qui à
jouer ce rôle Pas une fois,
c'est arrivé. Et enfin euh le
point important c'est que vous
notez que l'essentiel de
l'énergie qu'on utilise
aujourd'hui sur Terre et ce
qu'on appelle de l'énergie
fossile. Alors le dictionnaire
est bien fait, ça s'appelle
l'énergie fossile parce que
c'est des fossiles. Le charbon
c'est des fossiles de fougères
qui ont poussé à l'air du
charbon, le carbonifère il y a
trois-cent-millions d'années.
Alors ça a été très très
lentement cuit, beaucoup plus
lentement que la quiche aux
oignons dont je parlais tout à
l'heure. Euh très très
lentement cuit euh pendant des
centaines de millions d'années
sous terre. Hein euh le les
fougères des temps anciens se
sont enfouies par la des
plaques sous terre et puis ça a
été très très lentement chauffé
euh, par la chaleur
géothermique et ça a fini par
donner du charbon. Et euh, le
pétrole et le gaz c'est
exactement pareil sauf qu'au
lieu de prendre des fougères au
début vous prenez du plancton
et des petites algues euh, qui
ont vécu dans l'océan euh, et
euh, même punition euh, une
partie euh, tombe sur le
plancher océanique s'est enfoui
par la tectonique des plaques,
ça cuit euh, beaucoup plus
longtemps qu'une daube euh,
quelques dizaines de millions
d'années au moins et à
l'arrivée vous avez du pétrole
et du gaz Donc c'est pour ça
qu'on les appelle des énergies
fossiles, c'est vraiment parce
que c'est des fossiles. Je fais
une toute petite parenthèse, on
appelle parfois l'uranium
JANCOVICI fossile, c'est faux,
c'est un métal, c'est en
quantité, mais c'est pas un
fossile. C'est pas un reste de
vie ancienne, hein. Ce que vous
voyez donc sur ce graphique,
c'est que l'essentiel de
l'énergie qu'on utilise sur
terre aujourd'hui, c'est des
combustibles fossiles. Et euh
c'est vrai également, si vous
regardez un JANCOVICI que nous
JANCOVICI tous les jours, le
JANCOVICI de Christian Clavier,
vous savez, jour nuit, qui
s'appelle l'électricité. Vous
avez la manière dont on produit
l'électricité sur terre euh,
depuis mille-neuf-cent-quatre-vi
mille-neuf-cent-quatre-vingt-cin
water voilà donc dix-mille et
puis vous voyez ça augmente ça
augmente, ça augmente, ça
augmente. Aujourd'hui on est
passé au-dessus de
vingt-cinq-mille-milliards de
kilowatts heure électrique
produit. Alors, dans cette
histoire, qu'est-ce qui a
augmenté? Ben, le charbon a
augmenté et vous voyez que en
fait, en valeur absolue, sur la
période, c'est de très loin le
mode de production électrique
qui a le plus augmenté. Et même
si je regarde les vingt
dernières années, deux très
loin, ce qui a le plus augmenté
sur Terre, c'est la production
électrique au charbon. Alors,
comment est-ce qu'on fait de
l'électricité avec du charbon?
C'est assez simple. Avec le
charbon vous faites de la
chaleur, avec la chaleur vous
faites bouillir de l'eau, ça
vous crée de la vapeur et avec
la vapeur vous faites tourner
une turbine. C'est exactement
le même dans une centrale à
gaz, c'est exactement le même
principe dans une centrale à
pétrole et c'est JANCOVICI dans
une centrale nucléaire, à
chaque fois que vous faites de
la chaleur, c'est juste la
manière de faire la chaleur qui
est pas la même. Puis vous
faites de la vapeur, puis vous
faites tourner une turbine.
Hein? Vous voyez que le charbon
a beaucoup augmenté, le gaz a
considérablement augmenté
aussi. Alors le gaz c'est une
énergie fossile hein, aussi.
Euh un peu de pétrole. Là vous
voyez le nucléaire, là
l'hydroélectricité et là les
nouvelles énergies
renouvelables. Alors euh ce que
vous voyez c'est que dans la
production électrique dans le
monde, les deux décarboné qui
domine, c'est
l'hydroélectricité et le
nucléaire euh, arrivent ensuite
l'éolien euh, le biogaz et le
solaire qui sont à peu près à
parité, donc le solaire c'est
le petit machin orange que vous
avez là Donc l'essentiel de
l'électricité sur terre
aujourd'hui, les deux tiers
pour être précis euh, c'est des
énergies fossiles, donc
l'électricité c'est pas du tout
un JANCOVICI décarboné, suffit
pas de dire je fais de
l'électricité et parce que là
où je m'en sers, il y a pas de
fumée et ça pue pas. Du coup
c'est propre. Il faut aussi
regarder ce qui se passe là où
on la produit. Et en fait
l'électric est aussi propre ou
aussi sale que la manière de la
produire. D'accord? Elle elle a
les mêmes inconvénients que la
façon de la produire. Alors la
France est très atypique par
rapport au monde dans son
ensemble parce que vous avez
ici le même graphique pour la
France. Alors ce que vous voyez
pour la France c'est que le
petit la petite bande jaune là
que vous aviez ici là qui est
le nucléaire, c'est devenu un
gros gros paquet jaune en
France. Donc en France
l'essentiel de notre
électricité est produit avec du
nucléaire que vous voyez ici en
jaune. Il y a une quantité
hydroélectrique est à peu près
constante sur la période, parce
que les grands barrages ont été
dans les années septante,
soixante-dix, pardon, euh, je
trouve que les belges sont plus
logiques que nous sur le
numéro. Et euh, et et depuis,
on en fait plus, et la micro
hydraulique, pour ceux d'entre
vous qui en ont entendu parler,
ben le dictionnaire est nouveau
bienfait, c'est micro. Donc, ça
fait des toutes petites
quantités d'électricité. Euh,
les grandes quantités
d'électricité sont faits par
les grands barrages que vous
allez trouver dans les massifs
montagneaux. Et ce que vous
voyez, c'est que depuis euh,
deux-mille-cinq, en fait, on a
un peu baissé le nucléaire, un
peu augmenté euh, la la
quantité euh, d'électricité
faite autrement qu'avec le
nucléaire Par contre la
quantité d'électricité qu'on
fait avec des combustibles
fossiles sur la période a pas
énormément varié, alors elle
descend un peu, elle monte un
peu. Euh et en fait c'est bien
là qui est le problème en ce
qui concerne le climat. Il est
pas là, il est pas là. Euh et
euh il est pas là encore que
euh dans le solaire euh il y a
quand même cinquante grammes de
CO2 par kilowattheure. Donc le,
parce qu'il faut faire le
panneau. Donc le la partie
fossile dans la production
électrique française et c'est
celle-là qui est l'objet de nos
attentions si on s'occupe du
climat. Euh voyez ce qu'elles
représentent, elles
représentent la la la partie du
bas. L'essentiel de la
production électrique française
donc à à l'inverse de la
production électrique, Elle,
elle est déjà décarbonnée.
Hein, elle est décarbonnée
depuis euh, la mise en route du
programme nucléaire qui a pas
du tout été fait pour ça, hein,
il a pas du tout été fait pour
protéger le climat. Euh, mais
il se trouve que c'est un
avantage acquis euh, que nous
avons avec. Donc, j'en reviens
à mon pré-retraité. Euh, une
facture c'est pas vraiment la
bonne manière de voir la chose.
L'économiser c'est pas du tout
ce qu'on a fait. Alors
maintenant tout le va être
renouvelable Alors, j'ai une
très bonne nouvelle pour vous,
ça ne pose aucun problème. Si
si, ça ne pose aucun problème.
Regardez, voilà, un monde cent
pour cent renouvelable. Ça ne
pose aucun problème. Du reste,
ça pose tellement aucun
problème que le monde dans
lequel les hommes et les femmes
ont vécu depuis leur apparition
Il y a vingt-mille ans, pour.
Jusqu'à il y a deux siècles, a
été en permanence un monde cent
pour cent renouvelable. En
permanence. Donc, des points
d'échantillonnage pour un monde
cent pour cent renouvelable, je
vous en donne autant que vous
voulez, autant que vous voulez
Faire un monde cent pour cent
renouvelable ne pose aucun
problème aucun. Bon, mais on
n'a pas dû trouver ça si génial
que ça puisque ça fait deux
siècles qu'on passe notre temps
à sortir des énergies
renouvelables. Voyez, on avait
une marine renouvelable. Voilà
un bateau renouvelable en bois
renouvelable avec des voiles en
lin ou en coton renouvelable,
des marins renouvelables et
renouvelés du scorbut. Euh, et
navigant paisiblement sur la
mer renouvelable. Bon, et puis
on a dit c'est pas terrible,
c'est quand même vachement
mieux d'avoir ce genre de truc.
Bon. Voilà un transport
terrestre parfaitement
renouvelable avec un cheval
renouvelable et qui du reste
était renouvelé dans nos
estomacs. Il y avait des
boucheries Chevaline. Euh
mangeant de l'herbe
renouvelable tirant une
charrette en bois renouvelable.
Tout ça est parfaitement
renouvelable puis on a dit oh
c'est pas terrible quand même.
Il vaut beaucoup mieux avoir
ça, ça a l'air de mieux
marcher. Nous avions des
tracteurs renouvelables en
voici un, euh voilà ils étaient
comestibles à la différence des
tracteurs annuels, actuels, un
peu moins. Euh mangeant de
l'herbe renouvelable et cetera
puis alors on a dit ça c'est
même pas terrible on va quand
même faire ça. On avait des
travaux publics renouvelables
euh donc on faisait euh la Via
à Pia, les voies romaines et
cetera à la Manon des gens qui
mangeaient de l'herbe, enfin
pas de l'herbe, non, ils
mangeaient un peu mieux que ça,
souvent. Même les esclaves,
euh, puis on a dit, non, c'est
quand même vachement mieux de
faire ça, ça permet de faire
les lotissements beaucoup plus
vite, n'est-ce pas? De faire
vite. On avait une industrie de
la construction parfaitement
renouvelable, alors avec des
ouvriers renouvelables, qui
mangeaient là aussi de la
nourriture renouvelable, deux
siècles pour faire Notre-Dame
en première version, en
deuxième, Macron a dit que ça
JANCOVICI euh et on s'est dit
quand même, pour faire des
grands cornichons à la défense,
ça va beaucoup plus vite
d'avoir une construction
fossile euh, et donc on est
passé aux fossiles. avait une
JANCOVICI c'est pas de c'est
pas une deuxième manière de
fayoter avec Mélanie. On avait
une JANCOVICI euh parfaitement
renouvelable avec euh ici vous
avez une roue de moulin en bois
renouvelable, feu tournant avec
de l'eau renouvelable et cetera
puis on s'est dit non quand
même pour alimenter Toysa Ross
ça marche au mieux ça donc on
va faire ça On a même des
séchoirs à luzernes
renouvelables s'appelle le
Soleil aujourd'hui nous avons
des séchoirs à luzernes à gaz
beaucoup plus efficace et enfin
nous avions une aviation
renouvelable vous voyez ici le
premier aéronef euh des frères
montgolfiers avec du papier, le
papier c'est du bois hein euh
parfaitement renouvelable sur
euh un montant grâce à la
chaleur d'un feu de bois
parfaitement renouvelable puis
on s'est dit quand même, ça
c'est plus efficace. Bon bref.
Donc ça fait deux siècles en
fait qu'on passe notre temps à
sortir des énergies
renouvelables. Pas y aller, à
en sortir. Alors, je repose la
question, où on est des crétins
patentés, ou bien il y a une
raison physique pour laquelle
on a fait ça. Et alors, la
mauvaise JANCOVICI c'est qu'en
fait, il y a des raisons
physiques. Imaginons que on
prenne le volume de cette salle
dans laquelle je suis soit dit
en passant très heureux d'être
parce que euh depuis le covid
c'est la première fois que je
me retrouve dans une salle donc
ça faisait euh un an que
j'avais même pas mon mode
présentateur parce que quand on
fait des visions on l'a pas et
donc j'étais très très
malheureux. Euh donc imaginons
qu'on prenne le volume d'air de
cette salle en première
approximation je vais dire que
c'est un cube de dix mètres sur
dix mètres. Alors en fait bon
c'est à peu près ça le volume
d'air de cette salle. Je le
fais souffler à quatre-vingts
kilomètres heure. Donc vous
êtes pas dans le pays du sud
euh c'est pas du tout un
reproche donc le mistral et la
tramontane c'est pas trop votre
truc mais vous voyez
quatre-vingts kilomètres heure
ça commence à être un vent
sympathique quoi hein. Et
passer dans une éolienne. Vous
allez donc récupérer de
l'énergie. Vous allez mettre
l'éolienne en mouvement et
récupérer de l'énergie. Eh
bien, mille mètres cubes d'air
en mouvement passant dans une
éolienne ça vous fournit la
même quantité d'énergie que ce
que vous avez dans trois
millilitres de pétrole. Ça là.
Vous avez bien vu? Alors je
vous pose la question à votre
avis qu'est-ce qui est le plus
simple d'avoir trois
millilitres de pétrole ou
d'avoir une éolienne de
cent-cinquante mètres de haut
et d'y faire souffler mille
mètres cube d'air. À votre
avis? Bon, sans compter que
avec mon éolienne votre voiture
avance, si elle avance à
l'électricité, quand il y a du
vent, enfin non il y a une
batterie, c'est mauvais
exemple, mais enfin vous
comprenez l'énergie est
disponible quand il y a du
vent. Alors qu'avec le pétrole,
votre stock il est déjà là.
Votre pétrole il est
disponible, qu'il y ait du
vent, pas de vent, qu'il y ait
du soleil, pas de soleil, qu'il
fasse chaud, qu'il fasse froid
disponible. bon. Et en fait la
raison pour laquelle on est
passé du vent au pétrole, elle
est là. C'est à cause des
caractéristiques physiques
intrinsèques de chaque forme
d'énergie et qui fait que les
énergies considérables plus
denses, beaucoup plus faciles à
transporter, à utiliser
indépendamment des conditions
locales et donc ça a permis de
mettre en route tout un tas de
machines qu'on aurait jamais pu
mettre en route avec juste les
énergies renouvelables. C'est
pour ça qu'on a fait cette
transition des JANCOVICI
renouvelables vers les énergies
fossiles. À l'époque on s'est
pas dit, ça va JANCOVICI faire
du changement climatique, puis
un jour il y en aura plus. Vous
savez les gens euh moins inclus
euh un siècle c'est loin hein.
Donc euh on l'a fait puis on
l'a fait mais à cause de ça.
Hein? Et alors quand on regarde
aujourd'hui euh la la
traduction de cette différence
de caractéristiques physiques
vous avez un JANCOVICI en
France, bon j'ai pris en
France. Ça se balade quelque
part et huit centimes, alors
euh, l'offshore va vous en
coûter quinze. Euh, les très
bons gisements à terre
aujourd'hui euh, c'est
peut-être quatre, enfin, peu
importe. Euh, on a, dans ces
JANCOVICI six, huit centimes,
euh, un peu plus, un peu moins.
Et mais ça, euh, vous vous
faites opérer du genou s'il y a
du vent. Ou euh, la classe
démarre à huit heures s'il y a
du vent. Si vous voulez que la
classe démarre à huit heures,
même s'il y a pas de vent, faut
rajouter du stockage. Tête
d'accord Bon JANCOVICI du
stockage. Et donc à ce moment
le coût du stockage vous
multipliez par trois rats en
gros. Hein euh tout tout
compris. Donc on se balade avec
un kilowattheure éolien, avec
euh quelque chose qui va vous
coûter euh plusieurs dizaines
de centimes euh au moins vingt
à trente. De l'autre côté,
votre kilowatteur de pétrole,
je dis bien votre kilowattheure
de pétrole, sorti du désert
saoudien, déjà stocké, donc
déjà vous vous en servez comme
vous voulez. Il vous coûte une
fraction de centimes. Donc vous
avez un facteur de différence
de quelques dizaines entre
l'éolien et le pétrole et ça
reflète les caractéristiques
physiques intrinsèques de
chacune des énergies. Et
encore, ce facteur devrait être
beaucoup plus important.
Pourquoi? Parce qu'aujourd'hui
votre éolienne moderne elle est
fabriquée avec des combustibles
fossiles. Elle est fabriquée
avec du charbon pour faire la
métallurgie, pour faire
l'acier. Elle est fabriquée
avec du pétrole pour
transporter et JANCOVICI tous
les composants euh et puis par
ailleurs, pour faire les pales
en fibre de verre, et cetera.
Enfin en fibre de carbone. avec
du gaz pour faire le ciment qui
va servir à faire le plot de
béton. Si demain matin vous
avez plus tout ça parce qu'on
est dans un monde cent pour
cent renouvelable Est-ce que
vous pensez que le prix de
votre éolienne va rester le
même?
C'est pas sûr. T'es pas sûr
hein? Comme je dis parfois, je
suis pas sûr que je parierai
toutes mes économies là-dessus.
Bon. Euh en fait non. C'est
absolument certain que il ne
restera pas là. Donc en fait
aujourd'hui euh le coût des
énergies renouvelables n'est
pas élevée parce que nous avons
toujours un système fossile.
Mais si on veut se débarrasser
du système fossile
Et en
fait euh, le le le ça va
être ça le drame que je vais
sur lequel je vais continuer
d'élaborer ce soir. Euh je
pense qu'il y a un certain
nombre de gens, j'en suis même
sûr. Euh il y a deux siècles,
il y a trois siècles, il y a
quatre siècles, il y a cinq
siècles, il y a six siècles qui
étaient beaucoup plus
intelligents que nous tous
réunis dans cette euh je pense
que Mozart qui a composé des
symphonies à quatre à quatre
ans ou cinq ans, était juste un
génie absolu euh dont je ne
suis pas sûr qu'il est
déséquivalent euh depuis. Euh
je pense que Léonard de Vinci
et Archimède étaient aussi des
génies absolus et cetera donc
si ces qui était aussi
JANCOVICI n'ont pas réussi à
faire émerger une civilisation
industrielle. À l'époque des
JANCOVICI renouvelables.
Peut-être que la raison c'est
que il pouvait pas parce que
les énergies renouvelables
n'ont pas les caractéristiques
physiques intrinsèques qui
permettent de faire vivre huit
milliards de terriens comme un
smicard français Peut-être
juste ça, le sujet. Et en fait
c'est Allah que je voulais vous
amener. Euh donc là vous avez
trois réponses qui moi ne me
satisfont pas. Euh au sens de
pas le réflexe pavlovien qu'il
faut avoir quand on pense
JANCOVICI en fait le réflexe
pavlovien qu'il faut avoir
quand on pense JANCOVICI c'est
Iron Man. Voilà, c'est ça le
réflexe pavlovien qu'il faut
que vous ayez. L'énergie c'est
Iron Man. Il débloque
complètement et voilà il a
trois buts de vingt à l'apéro,
non j'en ai pas bu du tout. Euh
non pas du tout. Euh
effectivement l'énergie c'est
Iron Man ou plus exactement
l'énergie c'est la bibine
d'Ironman. C'est ça l'énergie,
c'est la bibine d'Ironman.
Alors c'est quoi Iron Man des
temps modernes? Évidemment vous
avez pas chez vous la l'armure
d'Ironman euh version rouge
pour les hommes, version rouge
pour les filles, bleu pour les
hommes. Non non c'est pas ça
que vous avez mais vous l'avez
quand même. Voilà à quoi elle
ressemble l'armure d'Ironman.
Et celle-là vous l'avez
vraiment chez vous. Le petit
doigt gauche d'Ironman c'est
euh le tractopelle que vous
avez là. Euh la main droite
d'Iron Man euh c'est le train
que vous avez là. Euh la bouche
d'Ironman euh c'est la machine
de filtration que vous avez là.
La mâchoire d'Iron Man euh
c'est la presse à outir que
vous avez là et cetera. En fait
Iron Man il est vraiment parmi
nous sauf qu'il est parmi nous
en pièces détachées en petits
morceaux et c'est l'ensemble de
la machinerie mondiale qui
s'est mise à travailler pour
nous Les vêtements que vous
portez puisqu'il est interdit
de venir tout nu dans cette
salle ont été fabriqués par des
machines. Ils ont été
transportés par des machines.
Vous les avez achetés dans des
magasins qui ont été construits
par des machines ou si vous les
avez achetés en ligne, vous les
avez achetés avec une machine
qui est un ordinateur, ils sont
passés par un entrepôt
constructeur des machines
acheminées chez vous par des
camions qui sont des machines.
Ce que vous avez mangé au
petit-déjeuner a été cultivé
par des machines, des tracteurs
et des moissonneuses-batteuses
réfrigérées. JANCOVICI par des
machines, éventuellement par
des machines nous vivons dans
un monde de machines et ceux
qui bossent c'est les machines.
C'est pas des hommes et des
femmes qui ont fabriqué des
fauteuils sur lesquels vous
êtes assis, c'est les machines
C'est pas qui est venu à pied
ici ce soir? Ben voilà, tous
les autres sont venus avec des
machines
Soixante chevaux attelés dans
le carrosse instantanément.
Donc nous vivons, ça c'est pour
les petites voitures. Nous
vivons donc dans un monde de
machines. C'est ça et donc
l'énergie c'est la nourriture
de ces machines. Donc en fait
plus on a d'énergie, plus on
consomme d'énergie en fait ça
veut dire plus on utilise de
machines. C'est ça qu'il faut
comprendre. Parce que c'est pas
vous qui buvez le pétrole.
Enfin en tout cas je vous le
déconseille, c'est pas
terrible. Euh si vous essayez
de vous mettre le truc de la
pompe à essence dans la bouche
là vous ferez de l'expérience
un jour. Euh je pense que vous
allez JANCOVICI moins bon qu'un
petit vin. Donc euh même pas
terrible. Donc euh le le
l'énergie c'est de la
nourriture pour machine et en
fait dire qu'on utilise de plus
en plus d'énergie en fait ça
veut dire qu'on utilise de plus
en plus de machines, qu'on a
une capacité à maîtriser notre
JANCOVICI et à le transformer
qui augmente. C'est ça que ça
veut dire. C'est juste ça que
ça veut dire. Alors on va
prendre des quelques exemples
de machines euh pour que vous
compreniez un peu euh de quoi
on parle maintenant. Euh
d'abord la première machine que
je vais prendre c'est vous.
Nous sommes, surtout les
hommes, des machines. Euh
c'est-à-dire que nous sommes
des convertisseurs d'énergie,
Beaucoup trop. Euh parfois on
boit beaucoup trop aussi. Euh
et derrière on va en faire de
la chaleur, beaucoup, parce
qu'on est des animaux, faut
qu'on se maintienne à
trente-sept degrés et du
mouvement un peu euh sauf quand
avachite dans son poste de
télé. Alors si on fait beaucoup
de mouvements, on se rendra
compte que la puissance moyenne
euh d'un organisme humain qui
est en train de travailler se
balade quelque part entre
JANCOVICI c'est ça que on va
constater. Alors cent watts
c'est par exemple quelqu'un qui
fait l'ascension Chamonix
Mont-Blanc dans la journée. Le
haut du Mont-Blanc hein, voilà.
Même si le Mont Blanc est pas
chez vous, je pense que vous
voyez à peu près de quoi je
parle. Euh et pour les
Parisiens euh même qui n'aiment
pas ça comme euh ça veut que
vous montez euh que je dise pas
de **** treize fois dans la
journée euh, en haut de la tour
Eiffel. À pied hein, je
précise. Euh JANCOVICI ouais
c'est ça. Treize fois treize
vous faites treize fois
l'aller-retour euh parvis euh
tour Eiffel à pied. Hein et ben
ça c'est une puissance moyenne
de cent watts que vos jambes
développent dans la journée.
Oui ça vous donne une petite
idée bon. Et si vous faites un
très grand trou pour de très
très gros JANCOVICI et que vous
décaissez quinze tonnes de
terre dans la journée euh là
c'est dix watts de puissance
moyenne pour vos bras et les
muscles du dos et les ampoules.
Donc voyez un un être humain
euh au travail c'est entre dix
et cent watts. Alors maintenant
je vais prendre un mixeur à
soupe. Vous voyez ce que c'est
un mixeur à soupe? déjà mixé de
la soupe ici
Il y a des mains qui se lèvent
pas. Non, il y a des gens qui
ont jamais mixé de soupe ici,
ou ils écoutent pas? Non, quand
même, bon ça va. Vous savez le
truc qui fait psitt là à votre
avis, quand vous appuyez sur le
bouton il faudrait combien de
personnes qui pédalent pour
mixer la soupe avec la même
puissance Vingt, vous avez un
mixeur en or, en argent massif.
Ouais, trois, trois, quatre.
C'est quand même beaucoup.
C'est quand même beaucoup. Ça
veut dire que quand vous
appuyez sur le bouton de ce
véhicule machin tout petit là,
qui fait visite, en fait, vous
avez la même puissance qui se
libère, que si vous aviez
instantanément quatre
domestiques qui arrivaient et
qui pédalaient pour vous. Mais
juste, c'est pas le même prix,
hein. Non, les enfants, c'est
moins. c'est pas le même prix.
Euh, alors maintenant euh,
après être passé à table, vous
avez mis des miettes partout et
vous passez l'aspirateur.
Alors, au moment où vous passez
l'aspirateur, il y a combien de
personnes qui pédalent pour
vous? En trois-mille, non ça
c'est un aspirateur industriel
ça. Non non euh, entre six et
dix. Un aspirateur euh,
maintenant c'est six-cents
watts mille watts entre six et
dix. Un bouton d'ascenseur
Combien de personnes qui
pédalent dans la cave pour
faire monter l'ascenseur? Pas
mal! Alors c'est pas cent mais
c'est cinquante. Ça fait cent
kilowatts en gros hein, moteur
d'ascenseur hein. Euh cinquante
personnes qui se mettent à
pédaler dans la cave. Quand
vous appuyez sur le bouton de
l'ascenseur. Ça en impose hein?
Bon alors maintenant un engin
que vous croisez probablement
de temps en temps par chez
vous. C'est Paris c'est un peu
plus rare. Un tracteur Eh bien
quand euh le conducteur du
tracteur monte dans la cabine
de pilotage du tracteur et ça
c'est un petit tracteur. Parce
qu'un tracteur de gros
céréaliers c'est plus puissant
que ça. Euh et bien vous avez
les de paires de jambes qui se
mettent à pédaler pour lui
instantanément. Et si je
prenais non pas euh mais des
chevaux eh bien un tracteur de
soixante kilowatts, un petit
tracteur c'est quatre-vingt-dix
chevaux attelés qui se mettent
à tirer tout d'un coup.
Quatre-vingt-dix. Juste un
petit tracteur comme ça. On va
prendre un engin de chantier,
indispensable pour que l'élu
puisse bétonner, non pardon
j'ai rien dit. Euh, et euh, qui
développe donc une centaine de
kilowatts euh, de de puissance
eh bien, vous là c'est comme si
vous mettiez instantanément la
totalité de la population de
sabler au travail avec des
pelles et des pioches un seul
engin, un seul engin. C'est
grâce à ça qu'on peut terrasser
un terrain en quelques heures
alors que dans les temps
JANCOVICI avec juste des pelles
et des pioches, ça prenait des
semaines. Ça c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles on peut
aujourd'hui se faire un
logement pour quelques années
de salaire, chose qui était
juste impensable il y a deux
siècles. C'était juste
totalement impensable il y a
deux siècles. Et du reste
l'étalement urbain, il y a deux
siècles c'était pas vraiment un
problème. Et la raison pour
laquelle c'est devenu
accessible à toutes les
bourses, les Allemands urbains,
c'est notamment ça.
voilà le camion euh dont je
vous parlais tout à l'heure.
Alors le camion lui il ****
comme quelques milliers de fois
les jambes de son conducteur.
Quelques milliers de fois les
jantes de son conducteur. Donc
pour assurer
l'approvisionnement alimentaire
par exemple euh de des des
villes euh de la du pays Eh
bien euh à chaque fois que vous
voyez un camion imaginez que
vous le remplaciez par un
attelage de quelques milliers
de personnes en train de
pédaler C'est ça la réalité
physique de la puissance qui
est capable de développer un
camion. Et alors là tout ça
c'est ridicule, maintenant on
va parler de trucs un peu plus
sérieux. Euh un avion. Cette
fois-ci c'est un million de
fois les jambes du pilote.
Alors le pilote pourtant il est
en forme, il est bronzé, il est
jeune et cetera. Un million de
fois les gens du pilote. Euh et
si vous prenez un Laminoir euh
eh bien un laminoir lui il est
capable d'écraser la tôle avec
la même puissance musculaire
que un sixième de la population
française. Un sixième de la
population française. On a deux
ou trois laminoirs en France,
on en a au moins à Dunkerque et
à Fos-sur-Mer. Euh à l'heure à
laquelle je vous parle, il y a
une personne dans la cabine de
pilotage du Laminoir. D'accord?
Une personne. C'est des
installations qui tournent
vingt-quatorze heures
vingt-quatre, mais une
personne. Alors évidemment, il
y a plein de gens autour euh,
la maintenance, machin interne,
une personne dans la cabine.
Donc lui, quand il rentre dans
la cabine de pilotage de son
Laby Noir, c'est vraiment Iron
Man, à tous les sens du terme,
du reste, parce que c'est Iron
dans le bon. Euh c'est, c'est
vraiment ça. D'accord? Pour
remplacer les deux laminoirs
français si je les avais pas,
j'aurais besoin de la totalité
de la population active
française, c'est-à-dire
vingt-millions de personnes
rien que pour taper sur des
tôles toute la journée tous
autant que vous êtes, vous avez
cette esclave énergétique là.
Vous avez des montures de
lunettes en acier, des boutons
de culotte en acier, sauf dans
la guerre des boutons. Vous
avez des fourchettes chez vous,
des cuillères, des couteaux,
euh vous êtes venus en voiture,
tout ça, donc tous autant que
vous êtes, moi aussi, hein, euh
on a utilisé euh ces esclaves
mécaniques des temps modernes.
Alors si je fais un petit
calcul d'ordre de grandeur,
avec toutes ces puissances
faramineuses de toutes ces
machines qui travaillent pas
nécessairement tout en même
temps, mais euh que nous avons
maintenant à notre disposition
Eh bien, on que ces machines
avec leurs croquettes pour
machines particulières,
c'est-à-dire l'énergie, elles
sont capables de développer en
moyenne sur deux-cents fois la
puissance musculaire de
l'humanité Alors maintenant je
vais vous le dire autrement, si
nous n'avions pas les machines,
votre pouvoir d'achat serait
divisé instantanément par
deux-cents. **** Instantanément
par deux-cents. Enfin le vôtre,
le mien. Instantanément. Ce qui
fait aujourd'hui la production
économique, c'est plus du tout
les gens. Du reste des gens il
y en a trop, c'est pour ça
qu'il y a du chômage partout,
c'est les machines Le premier
facteur limitant de la
production aujourd'hui c'est la
quantité de machines au travail
et la quantité de machines au
travail, c'est l'énergie, c'est
pour ça que je reviendrai,
c'est pour ça que c'est
l'énergie qui pilote JANCOVICI
En France, le facteur
multiplicatif deux-cents, il
est plutôt de six-cents. Alors
je vais vous le dire autrement,
ça veut dire qu'un Français
ordinaire, moyen, qui n'existe
pas comme chacun sait. Euh eh
bien il vit de la même manière,
s'il y avait pas de machines,
il lui faudrait six-cents
esclavages H vingt-quatre pour
qu'il vive de la même manière.
Donc l'énergie c'est le
vingtième siècle C'est pas euh
un un morceau, un truc qui
s'est passé. Non, l'énergie
c'est le vingtième siècle, sans
JANCOVICI nous ne serions pas
dans cette salle, on serait
éreintés après une journée de
la beurre à ramasser des
patates. Voilà, voilà où on
serait, en ce moment. Euh c'est
c'est l'énergie le vingtième
siècle. Alors évidemment euh ce
que je vous dis, ça déforme un
tout petit peu la manière qu'on
doit avoir de regarder
l'économie. L'économie que vous
avez apprise à l'école et moi
aussi, du reste est celle dont
on vous parle dans les débats
politiques, auxquels vous
participez peut-être de temps
en temps. Elle elle dit les de
la manière suivante. Vous avez
un système productif, celui qui
produit les fameuses richesses.
Alors ce système productif il a
deux facteurs de production.
Les gens qui travaillent et le
capital. Et si vous avez du
capital, grand et méchant comme
chacun sait, et des gens qui
travaillent à ce moment vous
avez une production et le
supermarché est rempli. Hein
c'est ça l'économie que vous
avez apprise à l'école et c'est
ça l'économie que j'ai appris à
l'école. Donc si la production
n'est pas assez forte,
qu'est-ce qu'on fait? On botte
le **** des gens qui
travaillent pas en leur disant
travail, feignant. Euh et on
dit au pied euh arrête de faire
n'importe quoi, investis dans
l'économie réelle. Alors en
fait ces deux choses-là, on
essaye de les faire depuis
deux-mille-huit et comme pouvez
le constater, ça ne suffit pas
à faire repartir la production
économique de manière
significative. Indépendamment
du covid. C'est donc
probablement que le système est
pas aussi simple que ça. En
fait, si vous demandez à une
personne, j'allais dire à
l'ingénieur, même pas à une
personne de simple bon sens, de
regarder physiquement le truc,
il va vous dire, mais attends,
pour avoir euh le le le tout ce
qui compose ces objets-là, là,
il a bien fallu les prendre
quelque part! Un verre, ça se
crée pas d'un coup de baguette
magique! Faut bien les matières
pour faire le verre! Un
fauteuil, ça un coup de
baguette magique enfin sauf
chez Harry Potter. Mais sinon
il faut bien les mathias et
cetera. Donc il va me falloir
quelque part sur terre la
matière que je vais pouvoir
transformer en JANCOVICI c'est
ce qu'on appelle les ressources
naturelles. Et puis il me faut
quelque part sur terre aussi la
capacité à transformer ces
ressources et c'est ça que je
vais appeler du travail. Hein
le travail c'est la
transformation euh de ce que je
fais autour de moi. Et en fait
cette transformation avec ce
que je viens de vous expliquer
vous comprenez que il y en a
une toute petite partie qu'on
fait nous et l'essentiel est
fait par les machines et leurs
croquettes pour machine
Alors, une fois que je vous ai
montré ça, vous prenez qu'il y
a d'autres facteurs limitants
dans l'économie et en
particulier si il y a un moment
où on manque d'énergie,
JANCOVICI pour des raisons
climatiques, c'est-à-dire on
s'impose d'avoir moins
d'énergie ou que ce soit pour
des raisons JANCOVICI a pu
faire un trou, il y a plus, il
y a plus de pétrole, hop! Il y
a plus, bon. Eh bien à ce
moment, vous aurez moins de
production. Alors en fait, les
deux sont valables, et ce qui a
commencé à se passer à petite
vitesse en Europe, c'est le
appui, quand on fait un trou
dans le sol, mais j'y JANCOVICI
tout à fait à la fin euh de euh
de ma présentation. Et puis euh
autre facteur limitant qui peut
s'appliquer, il y a plus de
ressources. Et en ce moment,
ben il y a plus de
transformation. Si vous avez
plus de pétrole, vous faites
plus de plastique et à ce
moment vous faites plus de
fauteuils en plastique. Et en
fibre synthétique hein. Dès que
vous avez des fibres
synthétiques quelque part,
c'est un dérivé du pétrole.
Donc euh euh nylon, désolé
mesdames, euh c'est du pétrole.
Euh polyester, polyuréthane,
enfin tous les polymachins
chouettes là. Euh ça c'est du
pétrole. Euh donc le du pétrole
il y en a absolument partout en
terme en en matières premières
également hein. Pas seulement
en en JANCOVICI. Et donc là
explique pourquoi, je vous ai
montré cette courbe-là tout à
l'heure. Vous voyez, le premier
déterminant dans ce graphique,
c'est la quantité d'énergie
dont on dispose, c'est ça le
premier facteur limitant, plus
il y en a, plus on a de
machines au travail, plus on
transforme de ressources, plus
on fait de plus on fait de
production, plus le PIB
augmente. C'est exactement ça
que je vous ai montré là. Et au
lieu de lire JANCOVICI en bas,
il faut lire quantité de
machines qui travaillent. En
fait, dès que vous voyez
JANCOVICI à partir de
maintenant, pensez machine au
travail. C'est ça l'énergie,
c'est une machine au travail.
Hein Alors comme cette
JANCOVICI est fossile, elle a
également une conséquence,
c'est qu'elle nous a conduit à
augmenter très fortement les
émissions dites de gaz à effet
de serre. Alors un gaz à effet
de serre à nouveau je vais vous
assommer avec un peu de
physique, mais malheureusement,
il faut le comprendre euh
voilà. Un gaz à effet de serre,
ça a une définition physique
très précise. C'est un gaz qui
absorbe le rayonnement
infrarouge émis par la surface
de la planète. Vous savez que
tous les corps émettent du
rayonnement. Le soleil émet du
rayonnement visible qui est
pour ça qu'on le voit, le
reste. Il émet également du
rayonnement ultra-violet
au-delà du visible avec des des
rayonnements qui sont plus
énergétiques, longueur d'ondes
plus courtes. Il émet également
de l'infrarouge mais de
l'infrarouge à courte longueur
d'onde, celui qui fait que on
sent la chaleur hein et la
terre qui est pas du tout à la
température du reste
heureusement pour nous parce
que six-mille degrés il ferait
un peu chaud. Euh elle émet
aussi du rayonnement mais du
rayonnement moins énergétique
puisqu'elle est moins chaude et
qu'on appelle de l'infrarouge
lointain. Hein c'est ça que
aimait la Terre. Eh bien le
rayonnement de la Terre il est
intercepté dans l'atmosphère
par ce qu'on appelle les gaz à
effet de serre. C'est ça leur
définition. Un gaz à effet de
serre, c'est un gaz qui est
capable d'absorber, qui est
opaque aux infrarouges
terrestres. exactement comme le
dossier de votre fauteuil est
opaque à la lumière. Voilà,
c'est même processus, vous
envoyez du rayonnement lumineux
de suite, absorbé, passe pas à
travers. Eh bien euh, les gaz à
effet de serre, vous envoyez du
rayonnement infrarouge euh,
émis par la terre dedans et ça
passe pas à travers, faut que
ça passe mal à travers euh, il
est absorbé. Et donc, plus je
mets de gaz à effet de serre
dans l'atmosphère, plus le
rayonnement est mis par la
planète a du mal à s'échapper
vers l'espace et plus ça
chauffe, il y a l'énergie qui
est confinée près de la
surface. Alors ça chauffe mais
pas que. Il y a des tas
d'autres déséquilibres qui
apparaissent. Ici avez euh, les
émissions de gaz à effet de
serre, de l'humanité depuis un
siècle et demi. Alors, là vous
avez le CO2 qui augmente,
essentiellement à cause de
l'usage de l'énergie fossile
croissant, mais aussi à cause
de la déforestation, la
déforestation est une des
causes des missions de CO2. Et
au-dessus vous avez un gaz qui
s'appelle le méthane euh, qui a
d'autres origines, notamment
agricoles. Alors, vous pouvez
aussi sur cette courbe, je vous
le je l'avais pas mis sur
l'énergie mais euh, voilà euh,
mettre d'autres trucs qui sont
censés nous décarboner, voyez
par exemple l'électricité ça
fait plus d'un siècle qu'on
s'en sert, ça a pas JANCOVICI
les émissions d'augmenter
l'informatique, ça fait
longtemps qu'on s'en sert, ça a
pas JANCOVICI d'augmenter. Euh,
pareil euh, en ce qui concerne
les trains, euh, pareil en ce
qui concerne Internet, et
pareil en ski, enfin voilà,
bon, après, ça continue
d'augmenter. Alors il y a une
très mauvaise nouvelle en ce
qui concerne les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre et en
particulier les émissions de
CO2 c'est que le CO2 il est
éternel une fois qu'on l'a mis
dans l'air Le CO2 est un oxyde,
vous savez dioxyde de carbone,
c'est ça que maintenant on dit
à vos bambins d'apprendre à
l'école, on leur interdit de
dire gaz carbonique, c'est
défendu, ils se font taper sur
les doigts avec une règle. Euh
maintenant on dit euh dioxyde
de carbone. Alors les oxydes
sur terre sont des formes
stable, chimiquement très
stable. Il y a un oxyde dont
vous vous servez tous les
jours. En tout cas, si vous
voulez pas se sentir mauvais,
qui est l'oxyde de hydrogène,
c'est-à-dire l'eau. Euh, tous
les jours, normalement, prenez
une douche, pourquoi? Bon,
bref. Euh, par un bain, c'est
pas bien. Euh, voilà. Pour pas
sentir mauvais. Eh bien, euh,
l'eau, ça fait des milliards
d'années que c'est sur terre
sous forme d'eau. Solide, hein?
Pas beaucoup de couple sur
terre, qui dure des milliards
d'années, hein? Bon, même les
deux là-bas, qui auraient pas
dû être à côté, l'un de
l'autre. Donc euh, les oxydes,
c'est des molécules qui sont
chimiquement très très stables.
Et euh, CO2 n'y fait pas
exception. Donc une fois que
vous le mettez dans l'air, il y
a rien qui l'enlève directement
tant qu'il est au milieu de
l'atmosphère. Ri pour que le
CO2 veuille bien ressortir de
l'atmosphère, il faut qu'il
revienne au contact du sol, où
là il peut arriver l'une des
deux choses suivantes, il est
absorbé par vos JANCOVICI donc
c'est la photosynthèse, euh à
ce moment le CO2 est repris à
l'air mais par contact avec les
feuilles de la plante,
d'accord? Il est pas au milieu
de l'air en contact avec un il
est et ça a besoin d'énergie
pour fonctionner, c'est pour ça
qu'on appelle ça photo-synt
vous avez besoin du JANCOVICI
de la lumière du soleil, c'est
ça l'apport d'énergie qui
permet à la molécule de CO2
d'être cassé. Hein sinon si
vous essayez de faire pousser
des plantes illégales dans un
placard sans éclairage, ça
marche pas. Donc ça montre bien
qu'il faut de l'énergie. Et
enfin, la deuxième manière que
le CO2 peut être, peut avoir
d'être pris à l'atmosphère,
c'est d'être dissout dans l'eau
océanique et ça c'est juste une
affaire de vase communicant.
D'accord? L'eau peut être
dissous dans l'air, enfin peut
être contenu dans l'air, il
peut être contenu dans l'eau.
Si en proportion, il y en a
plus dans l'air que dans l'eau,
ben ils passent dans l'eau,
pour partie, mais c'est
réversible. Si à un moment, la
concentration dans l'air
diminue parce qu'on réussit à
en faire ressortir, une partie
de celui qui est passé dans
l'eau ressort de l'eau. Hein,
c'est un processus de vase
communicant. à cause de ce que
je viens de vous dire Voilà le
drame, enfin oui on peut dire
le drame euh du changement
climatique Ce que vous dit
cette courbe, c'est qu'elle
vous donne la fraction d'un
surplus de CO2 qu'on a créé au
cours du temps après arrêt des
émissions. Dit autrement vous
on a créé un surplus de CO2
avec les émissions de CO2 qu'on
a faite dans l'atmosphère. Donc
il y a plus de CO2 aujourd'hui
quà un siècle. Question, ce
plus de CO2, en combien de
temps il s'évacue si on arrête
d'émettre? Eh bien cette donne
la réponse. Au bout d'un
siècle, il vous reste encore
quasiment la moitié de votre
surplus. Au bout d'un millier
d'années, il vous en reste
entre vingt et trente pour cent
et au bout de dix-mille ans, il
vous en reste encore dix et
vingt, entre dix et vingt pour
cent. L'atmosphère pour le
restant des temps historiques
ne reviendra jamais dans l'état
dans lequel elle était en
dix-sept-cent-cinquante.
Jamais. Ce qui veut dire que le
système climatique d'une
certaine manière, ne reviendra
Jamais! Pour les temps qu'il
reste à l'humanité à vivre dans
l'état dans lequel il était
avant le début de la
civilisation industrielle
JANCOVICI donc l'idée que la
pollution climatique est une
pollution qu'on peut supprimer
en prenant les mesures
appropriées est malheureusement
une idée qu'il faut se sortir
de la tête. On peut l'atténuer
et il faut le faire mais il y a
une partie de l'héritage du
passé qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut
plus refuser du tout. On va se
payer de toute façon. C'est ça
qui vous explique pourquoi le
climat à l'avenir va continuer
à dériver quoi qu'on fasse. Il
dérivera d'autant plus vite que
on essayera de profiter de
l'énergie fossile tant que ça
passe mais on ne peut plus
JANCOVICI cette dérive de
survenir désormais. Une autre
manière de dire ça, c'est que
le climat de l'an deux-mille
est perdu à jamais. qui est
déjà perdu à jamais. Voilà,
faut s'y faire. Enfin, faut s'y
faire, faut le prendre en
compte. Alors, bien évidemment
euh, ce problème-là s'échelonne
sur euh, des pas de temps qui
sont hors de l'entendement.
C'est un des problèmes euh,
qu'on a. Euh, ça va très
au-delà d'une ou plusieurs vies
humaines et surtout ça va très
très au-delà d'un mandat d'élu.
quels qu'ils soient, quels
qu'ils soient. Ça va aussi très
au-delà de la stratégie long
terme dans une entreprise
cotée, qui se balade entre six
mois et trois ans. Ça se balade
très au JANCOVICI avec on a
l'habitude de gérer nos
affaires aujourd'hui. Donc, un
des problèmes du changement
climatique, c'est ce qu'on
appelle la tragédie des
horizons, c'est-à-dire le fait
que la la les pas de temps
caractéristique du problème
sont en complet décalage avec
les pas de temps euh, des
organes de gestion que nous
avons mis en place
Aucun élu dans cette salle euh,
ne va euh, prendre ce que sera
la planète en
deux-mille-quatre-vingt dans
son programme électoral. Enfin
où ça va peser très très peu
hein Voilà, donc c'est ça un
des un des problèmes. Alors, je
mets plus de gaz à effet de
serre dans l'atmosphère. Du
coup, l'atmosphère garde plus
d'énergie près du sol et la
température moyenne au sol
augmente. C'est exactement ce
que vous montre cette courbe.
Alors, cette courbe, elle part
de dix-huit-cent-cinquante et
la température moyenne de la
planète, alors le le parc
convention, le zéro, c'est la
température sur le, la dernière
moitié du dix-neuvième siècle.
Et vous voyez qu'au
dix-neuvième siècle, la
température, on n'émet pas
encore beaucoup de CO2 dans
l'atmosphère, donc euh, ça va
encore à peu près. Et puis, au
vingtième si la température
moyenne commence à s'élever et
à l'heure à laquelle je vous
parle on a gagné à peu près un
virgule deux degrés par rapport
à l'époque pré-industrielle.
Alors vous allez me dire un
virgule deux degrés, bon ben
voilà bon un alors c'est déjà
suffisant pour que quinze à
vingt pour cent des coraux
soient morts sur terre. C'est
déjà suffisant pour que ça
aille contribuer à ce que un
tiers de la superficie
française est brûlée en
Australie il y a un an, un
tiers de la superficie
française quand même hein une
surface presque équivalente en
Sibérie la même année euh
allez, cette fois-ci plus
seulement dix pour cent,
ridicule de la superficie
française en Californie, a
brûlé encore la même année au
Payle euh, ça a brûlé aussi,
enfin bref, donc c'est déjà
suffisant pour que ça déclenche
et que ça favorise de manière
massive des feux de forêt euh,
dans le monde, c'est suffisant
pour avoir contribué, alors
j'ai pas le temps aujourd'hui,
mais j'ai une conférence qui
tourne sur Internet qui
s'appelle de Daesh à la Cop
vingt-et-un, si ça vous
intéresse d'aller la regarder,
je décortique pas, en quoi ça a
contribué au Printemps arabe
également et euh, à la au
déclenchement des troubles en
Syrie. c'est une goutte qui a
fait déborder le vase. C'est
pas ça fait pas déborder le
vase à lui tout seul. Mais ça a
été un contributeur. Ça a été
un déclencheur. c'est suffisant
pour avoir contribué à une
baisse de la récolte de pommes
de terre de quarante pour cent
en France il y a deux ans et
cetera enfin voilà on on
commence à en avoir des
traductions euh, aujourd'hui
euh, c'est suffisant pour avoir
euh, flinguer une quantité
significative d'épicéa euh,
dans les Vosges donc enfin ça
ça commence à arriver c'est à
un virgule deux degrés hein,
c'est c'est plus totalement
virtuel cette histoire Et ce
que vous voyez c'est à l'avenir
euh, quelle pourrait être
l'élévation de températures
moyennes euh, en fonction de ce
que nous allons faire. Donc, ça
c'est le scénario Mélanie
Connier euh, voyez euh on est
euh On voit pardon, c'est le le
en jaune là. C'est le scénario
euh Mélanie Connier. Euh donc
c'est un scénario dit accord de
Paris, c'est le scénario dans
lequel euh très très on appuie
sur la **** de frein en ce qui
concerne les émissions. Le
scénario euh rouge euh c'est le
scénario croissance infinie euh
dans lequel euh on émet de plus
en plus de CO2 parce que on a
une économie euh de plus en
plus florissante entre
guillemets euh et aucun facteur
limitant à l'économie jusqu'en
deux-mille-cent, c'est-à-dire
JANCOVICI JANCOVICI, JANCOVICI
de ressources, JANCOVICI voilà,
JANCOVICI des Martiens nos
gènes euh, la croissance
économique jusqu'en
deux-mille-cent. Alors, ce que
vous voyez c'est que
l'élévation de températures en
deux-mille-cent est très
discriminée en fonction de ce
qu'on va faire sur les
émissions. Par contre, ce que
vous voyez c'est que pour les
vingt années à venir, il y a
quasiment pas de différence
selon la couleur de la courbe.
C'est euh, la conséquence de la
grande inertie du CO2 dans
l'atmosphère dont je vous ai
parlé, en fait, quel que soit
le scénario, la dérive des
vingt prochaines années, elle
est déjà JANCOVICI c'est ça
qu'il faut avoir en tête. Ce
qui veut dire que non seulement
il va falloir s'occuper de
baisser les émissions pour quà
l'arrivée on soit plus près de
la courbe jaune que de la
courbe rouge en plus il va
falloir commencer à gérer des
désordres croissants et qui
vont continuer à s'amplifier et
qui vont continuer à
s'amplifier dans les décennies
à venir. De toute façon, quoi
qu'on fasse Le changement
climatique c'est un peu comme
une voiture pour laquelle au
moment où vous appuyez sur la
**** de frein, le premier truc
que fait la voiture c'est de
continuer à JANCOVICI pendant
vingt ans Hein, c'est ça le,
c'est ça le parallèle qu'il
faut avoir en tête. Alors
est-ce que quelques degrés
c'est beaucoup ou c'est peu? Je
vais essayer de répondre à
cette question avec euh, une
petite comparaison historique.
Vous avez ici euh, le genre
d'écosystème qu'on trouve en
Europe avant dire le début du
vingt-et-unième siècle euh, à
condition que on ne leur fasse
pas des misères pour mettre
autre chose à la place. Alors
le autre chose ça a été
essentiellement des cultures
euh, mais également des
infrastructures euh, et cetera.
Vous voyez que nous avons
essentiellement des forêts, ça
veut dire que le climat est
suffisamment doux et enfin pas
de JANCOVICI trop JANCOVICI et
surtout suffisamment humides
pour que ils poussent des
grosses espèces gétales Voilà
l'Europe il y a vingt-mille
ans. Alors il y a vingt-mille
ans le cadre des variations
climatiques naturelles, parce
que le climat a toujours varié
naturellement, par la même
vitesse que aujourd'hui, mais
il a toujours varié
naturellement. L'Europe est
beaucoup plus froide, on est au
coeur de la dernière JANCOVICI
. Alors ce que vous voyez
Fin euh bonne nouvelle pour
ceux qui aiment le rugby, les
Irlandais et les Écossais
étaient aussi sous la glace.
vous voyez, alors pour faire
euh, toutes ces grosses
calottes de glace, celles
posées sur la Scandinavie, sur
le Canada, il y en a également
une sur la Sibérie. il faut
bien avoir pris l'eau quelque
part, hein, tous ceux d'entre
vous qui font des glaçons dans
le frigo, sauf qu'en général
euh, ça c'est toujours pareil,
il faut prendre de l'eau pour
faire les glaçons. Alors, l'eau
qui a permis de faire ces
énormes glaçons, elle vient de
l'océan. Il y a eu un énorme
transfert d'eau par évaporation
et précipitations sous forme de
neige, très longtemps. Entre
l'océan et les continents. Et
du coup, le niveau des océans a
baissé de cent-vingt mètres,
puisque l'océan c'est une
grande baignoire et si vous
retirez de l'eau, ben euh, le
niveau de la baignoire baisse.
Et donc, Brexit puisque il y a
une continuité territoriale
entre la France et la
Grande-Bretagne, pas de paradis
fiscaux dans les JANCOVICI
puisqu'il y a plus d'angles
normandes euh, pas d'éoliens
offshore en mer du Nord puisque
il y a pas de mer du Nord. Donc
vous voyez que euh, le
JANCOVICI est très très
différent de ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui Le climat étant
beaucoup plus froid, il est
beaucoup plus sec, vous savez
quand le climat est très froid
en général, il y a peu de
précipitations, parce que il y
a peu d'évaporation, un climat
très froid est un climat dans
lequel il y a peu d'épargation,
peu de précipitations. Et donc,
les écosystèmes à l'époque, ils
sont froids et peu arrosés, ils
sont maigrichons. Et il ressent
que vous avez aujourd'hui au
nord de la Sibérie. Voilà à
quoi ressemblent les
écosystèmes de l'époque. Et
enfin euh à cette époque-là, la
la totalité de la population
française est bien inférieure à
celle du Mans, enfin de
l'agglomération du Mans. Euh
puisque la population française
dans son ensemble fait
cent-mille personnes en gros,
hein. Bon, le recensement était
pas très. Euh l'Insee était un
peu moins performante, mais en
gros, cent-mille personnes.
Quand l'Europe est passée de
l'État de gauche à l'État de
droite ça s'est fait dans le
cadre d'un réchauffement
planétaire global. Hein, vous
êtes d'accord JANCOVICI faire
fondre un glaçon en le
refroidissant ça marche moyen.
Donc il y a eu un réchauffement
planétaire, et bien ce
réchauffement planétaire, il
est juste de cinq degrés en
dix-mille ans. Donc là, vous
avez le résultat d'une
expérience grandeur nature
qu'on est capable de
reconstituer avec des analyses
du passé, qui vous montrent à
quoi ressemble l'évolution de
l'environnement avec un
réchauffement de cinq degrés en
dix-mille ans. Alors vous
pouvez me dire ah c'est cinq
degrés c'est vachement bien euh
parce que euh au moment de la
dernière JANCOVICI l'Europe
était incultivable, maintenant
elle est cultivable, c'est
quand même vachement mieux.
Alors je vais vous dire oui,
très bien, ce raisonnement a
quand même des limites euh
prendre vingt ans euh entre
zéro et vingt ans en ce qui
vous concerne, c'était une très
bonne affaire. Entre cinquante
et soixante-dix, ça doit
probablement se discuter un peu
plus. Donc une JANCOVICI de
température n'a pas toujours le
même bénéfice quel que soit le
point de départ et par
ailleurs, ça n'a surtout pas le
même bénéfice, quelle que soit
la durée d'application. Donc
là, si on parle de quelques
degrés en un siècle, c'est un
réchauffement cent fois plus
brutal que celui qu'on a eu à
cette époque-là. Donc je vais
vous le dire très très vite
parce que j'ai pas le temps de
détailler les conséquences ce
soir. La conséquence qu'il faut
retenir de un réchauffement de
quelques degrés en un siècle
c'est pas, on va mettre un pull
de plus ou de moins et on va
s'empailler pour savoir si les
écolos sont des gens
fréquentables ou pas, ça sera
la guerre partout. C'est ça,
quelques degrés de plus en un
siècle, ça sera la guerre
partout. Ça sera l'effondrement
des structures politiques
stables Sous les coups de
boutoir d'un défaut de
ressource qui s'appliquera de
manière massive à huit
milliards d'obsédentaires sur
terre. Hein le réchauffement
climatique c'est pas quelque
chose qui est juste un problème
d'inconfort où éventuellement
euh, de pommiers qui crèvent
dans le jardin c'est pas très
grave on mettra euh, autre
chose à la place non on est en
train de parler de quelque
chose qui a la capacité à
handicaper l'approvisionnement
alimentaire d'un certain nombre
de milliards d'hommes et vous
savez que quand on commence à
avoir des problèmes
alimentaires en général les
gens restent pas tranquilles ça
de porter atteinte aux
infrastructures de façon
absolument massive et cetera
donc en ça va provoquer des
désorganisations et ce qu'il
faut garder en tête sur ces
désorganisations c'est que ça
arrivera pas de manière
tranquille et prévisible ça
vous fera des covid.
C'est-à-dire dimanche tu
circules, lundi t'es claqueurée
chez toi euh, dimanche tout
allait bien, lundi ça va plus.
Ça va arriver par marche
d'escalier cette affaire. Hein,
ça va arriver par marche
d'escalier. C'est ça qu'il faut
avoir en tête hein. Et par
ailleurs comme l'expérience est
inédite Alors je je il y a des
dates conférences qui tournent
sur Internet auquel je vous
renvoie pour avoir des des des
conséquences plus détaillées de
tout ça. Euh, il faut pas une
seule seconde que la science
est capable de vous donner par
le menu toutes les conséquences
possibles en fonction du des
degrés de réchauffement. À
trois virgule cinquante-deux
degrés de réchauffement en un
siècle alors je risque très
exactement ceci sur la perte
d'approvisionnement alimentaire
en deux-mille-soixante-quinze
et très exactement le trois
juillet. Non, vous trouverez
jamais des trucs comme ça, ça
n'a aucun sens hein. Ce qui
veut dire que si on essaye de
mener l'expérience jusqu'à son
terme, ce qu'on va avoir c'est
essentiellement des surprises.
Il y a évidemment des mauvaises
surprises. Et le dictionnaire
étant bien fait, une surprise
c'est un truc pour lequel on
n'a pas eu le temps de
s'organiser. C'est bien pour ça
que je vous disais tout à
l'heure, ça prépare ce genre de
truc si on va jusqu'à son
terme, quelque chose qui
ressemble plus à des JANCOVICI
locaux ou régionaux, que à euh,
bon c'est un peu inconfortable
euh, on mettra la clim dans les
villes pour passer les vagues
de chaud et puis voilà ça ira
bien quoi. Hein, c'est pas du
tout ça qui nous attend. Alors
si on veut éviter le gag
Qu'est-ce qu'il faut avoir
comme ordre de grandeur en tête
et c'est là-dessus que je vais
terminer. Euh vous avez euh ici
une courbe qui a été enfin un
graphique qui a été par le GIA
qui a maintenant sept ans. Et
qui vous donne la réponse du
système climatique en
température, c'est l'axe
vertical en fonction totale de
CO2 qu'on met dans
l'atmosphère, c'est la courbe
horizontale. Alors plus
exactement la quantité totale
de CO2 qu'on met jusqu'en
deux-mille-cent. Donc on
démarre au moment où on joue
avec la machine à vapeur pour
la première fois. Et on va
jusqu'en deux-mille-cent, ça
c'est la courbe du haut, c'est
des milliards de tonnes de CO2.
Et ça vous dit de la planète va
se réchauffer, c'est euh,
l'échelle de gauche euh, à ce
moment-là en fonction de nos
émissions. Alors, pour donner à
ça un tour un peu concret, à
fin on avait mis dans l'air
deux-mille-deux-cent-milliards
de tonnes de CO2 depuis le
début de l'ère JANCOVICI en
jouant avec la machine à
vapeur, la machine à pétrole et
la machine à gaz. Hein. Et donc
ce graphique vous dit que
l'atmosphère température
planétaire va se réchauffer d'à
peu près un virgule cinq
degrés. Si on veut se limiter à
deux degrés, à ce moment on
fait le chemin inverse, on dit
ben voilà on a le droit
d'émettre trois-mille-milliards
de tonnes de CO2 dont
deux-mille-deux-cents ont déjà
été émises Et pour l'essentiel
depuis
mille-neuf-cent-quarante-cinq,
c'est-à-dire il y a
quatre-vingts ans. Il se trouve
qu'on est en deux-mille-vingt,
enfin deux-mille-vingt-et-un,
donc il reste quatre-vingts ans
jusqu'en deux-mille-cent. Il se
trouve que huit-cents c'est à
peu près le tiers de
deux-mille-deux-cents
Donc ça veut dire que pour les
quatre-vingts ans qui nous
restent jusqu'en
deux-mille-cent l'humanité a
collectivement le droit
d'émettre le tiers de ce
qu'elle a émis sur les
quatre-vingts ans qui viennent
de s'écouler à une époque où la
population planétaire était en
ordre de grandeur, deux virgule
cinq fois moins nombreuses Sur
l'ensemble de la période. Je
vais vous le dire autrement, ça
veut dire qu'un papy ou une
mamie qui meurt aujourd'hui à
quatre-vingts ans a émis sur sa
vie sept à neuf fois plus de
CO2 que ce qu'un bébé qui naît
aujourd'hui a le droit d'en
émettre sur sa vie sept à neuf
fois plus. Voilà, c'est ça les
deux degrés de l'accord de
Paris. C'est qu'un bébé qui
naît aujourd'hui, sur sa vie,
il a le droit d'émettre le
neuvième de ce que ses
grands-parents qui meurent
aujourd'hui ont émis sur leur
vie. Voilà. Ça c'est l'accord
de Paris. Alors vous comprenez
bien, une fois que je vous ai
dit ça, que ça va pas se faire
en un claquement de doigt et
vous comprenez bien avec ce que
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
sur l'importance des
combustibles fossiles dans ce
qui a fait. Parce que les
combustibles hostiles, c'est le
monde dans lequel on vit. C'est
le monde dans lequel on vit. Eh
bien, vous comprenez bien que
ça va pas se faire sans toucher
à tout partout et sans toucher
en particulier notre sac au
sein pouvoir
voilà Et en particulier si on
veut que ça marche à partir de
maintenant il faut que tous les
ans les émissions baissent sur
terre d'environ cinq pour cent
par an et cinq pour cent de
baisse sur une année c'est ce
qu'on a eu en deux-mille-vingt
avec l'année avec le covid donc
en gros les l'accord de Paris
c'est un covid de plus tous les
ans
Vous allez dire non. Bon, très
bien. Derrière. Allons boire un
coup tant qu'il y en a. Euh, on
va pas l'écouter. Alors, j'ai
une bonne nouvelle pour vous,
il y a également une
voiture-balai. La voiture
s'appelle la dépression des
combustibles fossiles. Car vous
avez un quelque chose qui met
cinquante à quatre millions
d'années à se former. Vous êtes
d'accord avec moi que c'est
difficilement qualifiable de
renouvelable aux échelles de
temps qui nous intéressent?
C'est très renouvelable à
l'échelle de cinquante millions
d'années. Mais bon, comme nous
on vit un peu moins longtemps
que ça, à nos JANCOVICI c'est
pas renouvelable. Ça veut dire
que vous pouvez pas en avoir
indéfiniment plus qui sort du
sous-sol. C'est pas possible en
fait les mathématiques vous
l'interdisent. Et alors euh là
vous avez un document qui a été
publié en deux-mille-dix-huit
par l'Agence internationale de
l'énergie qui est passée
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus
bas dans l'écran radar des
médias que à peu près n'importe
quel chien JANCOVICI , dans
quel village de France, mais
qui vous dit un tout petit
truc, juste un tout petit truc,
qui vous dit la la production
de pétrole conventionnel
c'est-à-dire tout ce qui n'est
pas le pétrole de schiste aux
États-Unis et les sacs de
bitumineux au Canada et passer
par un maximum mondial en
deux-mille-huit et ça décline
depuis. Qui était au courant
dans la salle? à part à part
les ayatollahs comme moi là,
personne, bon. Euh, donc ça
fait plus de dix ans que
l'approvisionnement pétrolier
décline dans le monde et il
décline pas parce que on a peur
du changement climatique. Il
décline juste parce que le
maximum des découvertes de
pétrole ça s'est passé à peu de
choses près l'année de ma
naissance que depuis ça décline
et que pour faire sortir du
pétrole de terre, faut quand
même commencer par le découvrir
si vous savez c'est compliqué
de le faire sortir Et voilà en
parlant de sortir quelque chose
qui sort du four euh qui est un
graphique JANCOVICI Project
euh, a publié, enfin ou à
JANCOVICI plus exactement avec
l'argent du ministère des
Armées. Donc on a des
fréquentations pas avoables aux
chiffres projects. Euh, on a
réussi à JANCOVICI un peu
d'argent des armées pour aller
travailler une base de données
extrêmement détaillée sur
l'ensemble des gisements
pétroliers dans le monde. Il y
a il y a trois sociétés dans le
monde qui détiennent des bases
de données très très détaillées
comme ça. L'abonnement annuel à
ce genre de base de données
euh, le tarif catalogue c'est
quelques millions de dollars
par an, vous vous doutez bien
qu'on n'a pas cet argent. Euh,
nous on a réussi à le négoci
pour une fraction de pour cent
de cette de ce montant-là mais
euh on a publié donc les
résultats et le le travail a
été fait par trois personnes
qui connaissent très bien le
secteur dont l'ancien patron de
l'exploration de Total. Donc on
peut pas nous dire que c'est
quelqu'un qui connaît pas le
sujet. Et le graphique vous
l'avez là euh sur la production
de pétrole des seize premiers
fournisseurs de l'Union
européenne. Donc on a pris les
seize premiers fournisseurs de
l'Union européenne, on a
regardé combien de pétrole ils
pouvaient produire à l'avenir,
sur la base de tous les
gisements inventoriés et ce
restant à découvrir et cetera.
Et le JANCOVICI aujourd'hui. Eh
bien vous voyez que même en
estimation haute, on ne revient
pas à la production pré-covid
deux-mille-dix-neuf et vous
voyez surtout que quelque soit
euh la le le la l'hypothèse
qu'on fasse sur le le sur le le
pétrole de schiste aux
États-Unis euh ça descend et à
un moment ça se met à descendre
très vite. Donc l'automobiliste
français que ça lui plaise ou
que ça lui plaise pas va devoir
faire avec moins de pétrole
même si le changement
climatique il considère que
c'est une lubie écolo. De toute
façon de toute façon hein. Donc
on va être coincé à l'avenir
entre euh le problème
climatique et le problème à
l'amont de ressource et c'est
dans cet univers compliqué,
désagréable, qui empêche de
faire toutes les promesses
électorales qu'on veut, qu'il
va falloir qu'on navigue.
Alors, avant de finir euh,
l'agence européenne de
l'environnement a publié en
janvier dernier or l'agence
européenne de l'environnement
est une institution officielle
de l'Union, exactement comme la
Cour de justice euh, ou euh,
comme la Commission. Hein,
c'est pas c'est pas une ONG.
Euh, donc l'agence européenne
de l'environnement a sorti euh,
en janvier un document qui là
aussi est passé totalement sous
les écrans radars euh, et qui
dit en gros la croissance verte
il y en aura pas. Voilà, si
vous savez lire entre les
lignes, donc s'il y a de la
croissance elle est pas verte
et si c'est vert il y a pas de
croissance. Voilà je vous le
dis très très brutalement,
c'est à peu près ça qu'elle dit
euh, et moi je rajoute un
deuxième truc qui est de toute
façon euh, qu'on le veuille ou
pas euh, la croissance c'est
l'énergie et de l'énergie il va
y en avoir moins à un moment ou
à un autre euh, et à ce moment
il y aura plus de croissance et
donc la question qu'on se pose
aujourd'hui au Shipproject et
je finis avec ça c'est comment
est-ce que on ne désespère pas
Billancourt dans un monde sans
croissance et euh, comment
est-ce qu'on fait pour régler
le problème climatique en ne
comptant pas sur de plus en
plus de moyens pour le faire
voilà c'est très exactement ça
la question qu'on se pose parce
que à mon sens c'est très
exactement la question qu'il
faut se poser aujourd'hui elle
peut être très désagréable
peut-être que à la fin de cet
exposé vous vous dites que vous
auriez mieux fait de rester
chez vous mais en attendant
euh, c'est malheureusement très
exactement ça la question qu'il
faut qu'on se pose euh, quand
on a bien fait le tour de des
contours physiques euh, du
problème voilà et j'ai été très
bavard et donc là je m'arrête,
mon train est demain matin,
donc là vous pouvez y aller.
Merci Monsieur JANCOVICI on va
prendre euh les questions euh
en ligne, enfin sur le
téléphone à la volée Est-ce que
vous voulez qu'on répète le
numéro? Est-ce qu'on peut
l'afficher s'il vous plaît
monsieur Garnier? Non, alors je
le redonne. Je retrouve ma
fiche
Donc vous pouvez nous envoyer
des SMS au zéro six
soixante-dix-huit quinze
quatorze soixante-trois. Zéro
six soixante-dix-huit quinze
quatorze soixante Je le
répéterai hein s'il faut.
Alors on va commencer avec la
première question.
Alors, une première question
euh, alors revenant sur euh, le
descriptif des différents types
d'énergie que vous avez euh,
présenté euh, quelqu'un pose la
question suivante euh, vous
disiez que du coup que euh,
photovoltaïque ça crée en gros
cinquante grammes de CO2 par
JANCOVICI en tout cas c'est ce
qu'il fallait euh, donc une
remarque tout simplement que
vous allez pouvoir euh,
peut-être euh, euh, argumenter
euh, cet euh, cet internotateur
du coup dit donc il est inutile
de payer de l'électricité verte
puisque existe pas finalement.
Alors il y a beaucoup de
questions en fait euh dans
cette affirmation simple. Euh
la première c'est est-ce que ça
a du sens de mettre un adjectif
euh derrière de l'électricité?
Euh en fait non. Euh
l'électricité elle est euh le
le le côté vert est quelque
chose qui ne se manifeste pas
euh dans l'électricité.
on peut quantifier les
émissions de gaz à effet de
serre que l'on fait pour
produire un JANCOVICI ça ça
existe. Euh après vers ben on
peut décider que c'est à partir
de cinquante grammes sévères, à
partir de cent grammes de CO2
par kilowattheure sévère, à
partir de quatre-cents sévères,
à partir de deux sévères, ouais
voilà. Donc euh vert ça a pas
de contenu normatif. Euh si je
vous donne les ordres de
grandeur en ce qui concerne la
production électrique, ils sont
les suivants. Pour faire un
JANCOVICI au charbon c'est
mille grammes un JANCOVICI un
JAN gaz, c'est à peu près
quatre-cents grammes de CO2 par
kilowatt heure électrique,
kilowattheure au pétrole, c'est
à peu près huit-cents, si vous
faites de l'électricité au
pétrole, il y a il y a il y a
il y a encore hein des turbines
au fioul. Euh si vous faites du
photovoltaïque c'est à peu près
cinquante, alors vous allez me
dire le panneau n'émet pas de
CO2, ben oui, c'est tout à fait
vrai, le panneau n'aime pas de
CO2. Il a fallu pour avoir
JANCOVICI photovoltaïque, faire
le panneau. Alors faire le
panneau, c'est fondre du
silicium, ça ça demande de
l'énergie, c'est faire un cadre
en acier, ça demande de
l'énergie, c'est mettre un
onduleur, et cetera. Donc si la
totalité de ce qu'il faut avoir
pour que le panneau puisse
fonctionner et que vous
rapportez ça à la durée de vie
du panneau, c'est comme ça que
ça marche hein, une analyse, eh
bien vous vous rendez compte
que sur sa durée de vie en
France, parce que évidemment
dans le désert saoudien ça
serait deux fois plus faible,
puisqu'il y a deux fois plus de
production, plus de soleil en
Norvège, ça serait deux fois
plus fort parce que euh la
Norvège est un pays un peu
moins insolé que la Côte
d'Azur, eh bien euh vous avez
même que le Pays Sarthe euh eh
bien euh vous avez un un un
contenu carbone pour le
photovoltaïque en France qui
est de l'ordre de cinquante
grammes. Après euh si je vais
sur les barrages, l'éolien et
le nucléaire, on se promène aux
alentours de dix. Un peu plus,
un peu moins, euh, ça dépend,
sauf dans un cas très
particulier du barrage de
Petit-Sault en Guyane où euh,
au moment où on a mis en eau le
lac de barrage, on a noyé la
végétation qui s'y trouvait,
elle se décompose en faisant du
méthane et vous rapportez cette
production de méthane à la
production électrique du
barrage, le barrage de
Petit-Saut en Guyane émet
autant qu'une centrale à gaz.
Voilà. Mais c'est vraiment une
bizarrerie, on va dire dans le
monde des barrages. du coup
euh, je vais en profiter pour
faire une euh, une un
complément euh, ça veut dire
que en France quand on dit
qu'on veut remplacer du
nucléaire qui est à dix grammes
de CO2 par de l'éolien et du
solaire qui sont respectivement
à dix et à cinquante c'est un
débat hors climat, c'est pas un
débat qui concerne la
décarbonation de la France
alors, c'est un débat hors
climat, si vous remplacez un
truc à dix par un truc à dix
sur le plan du climat c'est
équivalent, si vous remplacez
un truc à dix par un truc à sur
le plan du climat c'est même un
peu moins bien hein La seule
justification à faire baisser
le nucléaire, c'est si on on
est tellement contre le
nucléaire qu'on veut n'importe
quoi sauf du nucléaire. Mais
c'est pas du tout une
justification climat. Je vous
le dis parce que euh le
discours officiel mélange à
dessin les deux en permanence.
Discours gouvernemental en ce
moment est un joyeux
globi-bulga dans lequel les
deux sont mélangés en
permanence. Voilà donc je
précise juste ça.
Pardon, aussi il y a un dernier
truc que je voulais dire sur
l'électricité verte. Quand vous
pensez acheter de l'électricité
verte parce que vous achetez un
fournisseur d'électricité
verte. En fait, vous n'achetez
pas une électricité différente
de celle de votre voisin. Vous
êtes physiquement connectés au
même réseau que lui. Donc en
fait, un distributeur
d'électricité verte. Vous vend
pas un produit qui est
physiquement différent du
produit que vous achetez chez
le voisin. En fait, tout le
monde est sur le même réseau.
Un réseau électrique c'est très
simple hein, c'est un gros
abreuvoir dans lequel vous avez
plein de robinets ouverts, ça
c'est les centrales électriques
et plein de tuyaux qui
soutirent. Ça c'est les
Conférence hein et au milieu
vous avez le réseau qui est un
truc qui mutualise. Bon quand
vous avez euh deux-cents
robinets qui sont ouverts dans
un abreuvoir et deux-cents
pailles de gens qui boivent
dans l'abreuvoir, est-ce que
vous pouvez dire moi je bois
l'eau de tel robinet? Non! Vous
buvez l'eau de l'abreuvoir
comme votre voisin! D'accord?
Tout le monde boit la bémo. Ben
l'électricité c'est exactement
pareil, euh tout le monde
utilise physiquement la même
électricité. Alors pourquoi
est-ce qu'on dit qu'elle est
verte? Ça le mécanisme de
verdissement entre guillemets
correspond à la chose JANCOVICI
les producteurs d'électricité
renouvelables en France qui ne
bénéficient pas d'un tarif
d'achat garanti, c'est-à-dire
essentiellement les barrages
ont le droit de séparément
leurs kilowatts heure et ce
qu'on appelle un certificat de
garantie d'origine,
c'est-à-dire le fait qu'il y a
un JANCOVICI qui existe quelque
part et ce cas de garantie
d'origine va vivre sa vie
indépendamment du kilowattheure
qui a été vendu par le
producteur d'électricité
renouvelable. Et donc le
distributeur d'électricité dite
verte l'achète ce certificat,
donc par exemple Total Energie
et vous vend le certificat avec
le contrat de distribution
d'électricité mais qui en
pratique que vous restez
physiquement branchés au même
endroit. Du reste si vous avez
changé de distributeur
d'électricité, vous allez pas
changer de branchement.
Personne n'est venu chez vous
en disant attendez je vous
débranche les trucs du réseau
là puis je vais tirer un câble
qui va aller jusqu'à cent
bornes là où se trouve
l'éolienne, C'est pas du tout
ça qui se passe. Euh ce qui se
passe c'est que vous restez
branchés exactement aux mêmes
réseaux, vous consommez
exactement la même électricité
mais la convention qu'on vous
applique a juste changé.
D'accord? Mais cette convention
ne change pas la réalité Et en
fait ces certificats de
garantie d'origine c'est juste
du rofit additionnel pour les
détenteurs de barrages euh,
essentiellement euh, qui sont
capables de vendre ces
certificats je le disais euh,
des kilowatts. Voilà, donc en
fait cette cette notion
d'électricité verte euh, au
sens de l'article qui vient
d'être amendé dans la loi
climat euh, à l'Assemblée
nationale et ça c'est plutôt
c'est une très bonne chose
devrait être interdite, ça
devrait être assimilé à la
publicité mensongère
Alors bon puisqu'on est sur les
questions euh de de production
d'énergie du coup une autre
question euh par rapport au
biogaz. Euh est-ce que pour
vous c'est une alternative qui
peut être viable? Est-ce que ça
peut se faire en circuit court?
Euh voilà qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire dessus?
Alors si je sur le biogaz, si
je reprends euh si je fais le
le le comment dire si je me
mets dans la continuité de la
réponse précédente? Euh en
France je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure, l'électricité est déjà
décarbonnée. Euh donc si on se
place dans une optique dans
lequel ce qui est la mienne
hein euh où la course contre la
montre elle est avant tout sur
le sujet climatique et avant la
dépendance à une énergie
fossile importée qui sera pas
éternelle euh, la première
chose à laquelle euh, le
premier problème auquel on
s'attaque c'est les énergies
fossiles pas euh, l'électricité
nucléaire. Mais encore une fois
c'est mon point de vue. À ce
moment les bonnes énergies
renouvelables sont celles qui
permettent de substituer les
combustibles fossiles. Alors
qu'est-ce qu'on a comme bonnes
énergies renouvelables qui
permettent de substituer des
combustibles fossiles? On a
tout ce qui dérive de la
biomasse dans la mesure où
c'est utilisé de manière
soutenable et en particulier il
peut y avoir le biogaz. Donc le
biogaz c'est quoi? C'est vous
prenez de la matière organique,
vous faites fermenter ça euh,
comme dans un vulgaire marécage
euh, sauf que vous mettez ça
dans un digesteur où vous
récupérez le méthane, au lieu
que ça vous fasse des fofollets
et à ce moment euh, ce méthane
vous pouvez l'utiliser, c'est
comme du gaz naturel, c'est la
même chose euh, vous pouvez
l'utiliser pour un JANCOVICI
euh, un JANCOVICI ou avant vous
JANCOVICI des énergies
fossiles. Alors, de mon point
de vue, le bioga c'est
intéressant. Le premier
JANCOVICI pour lequel c'est
intéressant c'est de substituer
les combustibles fossiles dans
le monde agricole lui-même.
Donc, le premier JANCOVICI pour
le biogaz c'est de remplacer le
fioul de la mécanisation
agricole par du biogaz. On sait
faire aujourd'hui des gros
moteurs à gaz euh, et cetera.
Deuxième JANCOVICI qui peut
être intéressant, alors là
c'est toujours en circuit court
entre guillemets, c'est tout ce
qui est transport en commun et
transport de marchandises, pas
très loin de là où le biogaz a
été fait. Hein, euh, donc ça
peut être la des des dessertes
scolaires, les camionnettes de
livraison euh, et cetera euh,
voilà. Par contre euh, toujours
pour vous donner un ordre de
grandeur, on utilise
aujourd'hui de cinq-cents, un
peu moins,
quatre-cent-cinquante-milliards
de kilowatts heure de gaz
fossile Si avec le biogaz, on
arrive dans
quatre-cent-cinquante-milliards
de gaz fossiles, si avec le
biogaz on arrive à cinquante
milliards, ça sera déjà
vachement beau. Donc on peut
pas imaginer faire du biogaz
pour remplacer le gaz de toutes
les chaudières à gaz euh, qu'on
a aujourd'hui, ça
malheureusement ça passera pas.
je suis en même temps donc euh
alors euh encore une question
sur euh les productions
d'énergie donc sur le nucléaire
euh la question suivante est
ben la question est la suivante
donc le nucléaire pour vous
est-il est-elle la meilleure
solution et aussi dans euh la
prise en compte du coût carbone
du nucléaire est-ce que vous
prenez en compte tous les tous
les coûts x notamment liés au
démantèlement, au stockage, au
JANCOVICI des déchets et cetera
et cetera. D'accord. Alors
c'est une réponse technique et
une réponse plus sociétale. Sur
la sur la technique, est-ce
qu'on prend tout en compte
quand on fait le coût carbone
du nucléaire? La réponse est
oui, et alors la raison pour
laquelle on arrive à des petits
chiffres pour le nucléaire,
tient à la nature même de
l'énergie, exactement comme
j'ai comparé le vent et le
pétrole en montrant qu'il y
avait une question de densité,
eh ben je vais réappliquer ce
raisonnement au nucléaire.
L'énergie nucléaire est une
énergie considérablement plus
dense que l'énergie de la
combustion. Donc l'énergie de
la combustion, c'est de
l'énergie chimique hein.
L'énergie nucléaire elle est
des millions de fois plus
denses. En fisionnant un gramme
d'uranium, vous libérez autant
d'énergie que en brûlant une
tonne de pétrole. Ce veut dire
que l'énergie nucléaire met en
jeu des toutes petites
quantités de matière pour
produire des grandes quantités
d'énergie. Alors c'est
justement parce que vous avez
beaucoup d'énergie dans un
petit volume que il faut bien
s'en protéger donc que vous
mettez du béton puis encore du
béton puis encore du béton puis
encore du béton. C'est
justement à ça que c'est ça
l'origine. Un peu plus que
quand vous avez un moteur de
voiture. Mais par contre euh
l'avantage c'est que derrière
vous manipulez des petites
quantités de matière pour avoir
des grandes quantités
d'énergie. Or le CO2 du cycle
il est lié à la quantité de
matière qu'on manipule la
quantité de minerais qu'il faut
aller chercher, la quantité
d'acier et de béton qu'il faut
couler pour faire le réacteur
et cetera. Donc vous allez à
faire par rapport à la quantité
d'énergie libérée manipuler des
petites quantités de matière
donc émettre
proportionnellement à l'énergie
des petites quantités de CO2
c'est de là que vient le
contenu carbone et par contre
l'énergie nucléaire elle-même
ne fait pas de CO2, casser un
noyau d'uranium en deux, c'est
pas comme oxyder un atome de
carbone, donc ça fait pas de
CO2 ça. Donc le CO2 X j'ai
envie de dire, comme il est
rapporté à des quantités de
matières qu'on manipule qui
sont beaucoup plus faibles que
avec euh d'autres formes
d'énergie, du coup vous avez un
contenu carbone qui est très
bas. Euh c'est ça qui explique
même en tenant compte du
démantèlement, de
l'enrichissement de enfin de ce
qu'il y a à l'amont, à Laval et
cetera. Alors après est-ce que
le nucléaire est la solution?
Si la question c'est est-ce que
le nucléaire est la solution et
que je complète en pour
conserver le niveau de vie que
nous avons aujourd'hui sans
combustibles fossiles dans le
monde? La réponse est non. La
mauvaise nouvelle hein Même le
nucléaire suffira pas. Parce
que il est trop bas aujourd'hui
il devrait se déployer trop
vite pour remplacer tous les
combustibles fossiles en trente
ou quarante ans, ça passe pas.
Par contre plus on en fait plus
l'effort de sobriété qu'on va
devoir faire, alors c'est quoi
la sobriété? C'est passer de la
voiture au vélo, électrique
euh, c'est passer de quarante
mètres carrés habitables par
personne à trente euh, c'est et
cetera, c'est manger moins de
viande, c'est ça hein, la
sobriété hein et c'est avoir
euh, moins d'objets euh, de
tout et n'importe quoi euh, qui
s'entassent dans la cave euh,
ou dans la corbeille de
l'entrée, la Comédie Gad
Elmaleh parce que ça peut
toujours servir un jour.
JANCOVICI euh, eh bien euh, la
sobriété c'est ça, bah, plus on
fera de nucléaires, moins on
fera d'effort sur la sobriété
mais on en fera quand même.
Hein donc la manière que j'ai
de présenter le nucléaire comme
la solution en fait c'est un
élément de solution qui permet
de nous alléger l'effort et de
nous l'alléger plus
efficacement que les JANCOVICI
diffusent. Tout simplement
parce que c'est pilotable. Donc
là on renvoie à la physique euh
indépendamment de tous les
débats sur les coups qu'on
pourrait on pourrait y passer
la nuit. Euh eh bien en fait le
nucléaire étant pilotable et
manipulant des petites
quantités de matières, il est
physiquement intrinsèquement
supérieur aux énergies et non
pilotables. Ce qui veut dire si
on fait du nucléaire, on on a
un effort important sur la
sobriété euh, mais si on en
fait pas, on a un effort
considérable. Voilà, c'est un
peu comme ça que il faut voir
les choses. Euh, et c'est ça
qui explique que je suis à la
fois pour, tout en disant, mais
c'est pas du tout suffisant
euh, pour nous exonérer euh,
d'efforts absolument euh, à
faire sur le reste. Alors du
coup est-ce que euh le futur
l'avenir ce serait pas d'avoir
un mix énergétique euh le plus
large possible et non pas tout
concentrer sur un ou deux types
d'énergie seulement. Alors la
diversification euh est quelque
chose qui paraît être un
argument de bon sens, c'est
évident. Euh on vous dit tout
votre médecin par exemple vous
dit il faut que vous ayez une
alimentation diversifiée. En
fait on confond souvent deux
choses qui sont diversifiées et
équilibrées. Mais il y a des
diversifications qui sont euh
du tout pertinentes. Alors une
blague que je fais souvent, je
suis désolé si ça concerne la
famille de JANCOVICI dans
l'assistance euh et de dire si
je vous coupe une de vos deux
jambes pour la remplacer par
une jambe de bois, j'ai
diversifié vos appuis.
D'accord? Avant vous aviez deux
jambes JANCOVICI après vous
avez deux jambes différentes.
Vous êtes d'accord avec moi?
J'ai diversifié vos appuis.
Bon, je suis pas sûr qu'il y
ait beaucoup de gens dans la
salle qui vont considérer que
j'ai amélioré leur situation.
Donc la diversification c'est
pas un argument d'autorité pour
que ça devienne mieux au sens
du régime alimentaire
équilibré, il faut que ce avec
quoi vous diversifiez soit
mieux que ce que ça remplace.
Mais si c' mieux que ce que ça
remplace. Vous vous êtes pas
diversifié, vous vous êtes
affaibli hein. Donc la
frontière entre la
diversification et
l'affaiblissement, le fameux
mix bon bah euh ça dépend avec
quoi vous remplacez. Je vais
vous donner un autre exemple
euh vous ne mettez que de la
nourriture dans votre bouche
pour manger. Je sais pas bien,
faut diversifier, mettez-y des
cailloux. ou de l'acide
chlorhydrique. Bon, oui. Donc,
la diversification, oui, à
condition que ça soit avec
mieux que ce que ça remplace.
Euh, si c'est avec moins bien
que ce que ça remplace, je le
redis, ça non seulement ça ne
vous amène pas de bénéfices,
mais ça vous affaiblit.
Euh d'accord. Alors du coup
encore euh deux questions sur
les JANCOVICI après on va
passer sur un autre thème. Euh
l'hydrogène on en parle
beaucoup en ce moment notamment
euh pour une possible future
JANCOVICI dans les transports
en grosse partie ou dans les
procédes industrielles,
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez?
Alors l'hydrogène n'est pas une
source d'énergie disponible
dans la nature. Il y a quelque
chose que j'ai pas eu le temps
de dire ce soir mais que je
vais vous rappeler donc je vais
revenir à la physique. Horreur!
En physique il y a une loi qui
est extrêmement bien connue,
qui est un une loi une des lois
cardinales de la physique qui
s'appelle la loi de
conservation de l'énergie. La
loi de l'énergie vous dit un
truc qui est euh, tout bête.
Elle vous dit dans un système
qui est clos, qui ne communique
pas avec l'extérieur, la
quantité d'énergie que vous
avez est rigoureusement
constante au cours du temps.
C'est très simple comme loi, ça
se conserve. C'est comme une
boîte de conserve, l'intérieur
d'un système clos, l'énergie.
Alors, pourquoi est-ce que
c'est important euh, pour
arriver à l'hydrogène? Euh,
tout simplement parce que à ce
moment, si vous regardez euh,
l'humanité pris comme un
système, eh bien, pour disposer
d'énergie, l'humanité doit
communiquer avec l'extérieur.
L'humanité de pas créer
d'énergie en son sein sans
communiquer avec l'extérieur.
Donc toutes les énergies qu'on
peut utiliser. elles doivent
déjà être à l'extérieur. Donc
l'énergie pour les hommes et
les femmes, ça veut dire
quelque chose qui existe déjà
dans l'environnement et qu'on
peut exploiter à notre profit.
Alors correspondre à cette
définition, le charbon qui
brûle tout seul, le gaz qui
brûle tout seul, le pétrole,
qui brûle tout seul, les chutes
d'eau, qui fournissent toute
seule de l'énergie, le vent qui
souffle tout seul, le
rayonnement solaire, qui
fournit tout seul de l'énergie,
les noyaux d'uranium qui se
cassent en JANCOVICI et cetera.
Mais il y a pas les là-dedans.
Il y a pas sur terre d'endroit
où il y ait un réservoir
d'hydrogène, enfin il y en a
quelques sources mais enfin
elles sont ridicules. Euh mais
enfin il y a un peu d'énergie
mais c'est tout petit. Sinon il
y a pas de réservoir
d'hydrogène. Donc l'hydrogène
il faut le faire. C'est comme
l'électricité. Tant que vous
aurez pas trouvé le moyen de
brancher les cafetières sur les
éclairs d'orage l'électricité
c'est pas une source que vous
trouvez dans la nature. Faut la
faire. Je vous ai montré tout à
l'heure comment. Eh ben
l'hydrogène c'est pareil, il y
en a plein dans la nature.
C'est le premier constituant de
l'univers. Il y en a plein sur
terre. C'est le constituant
principal de l'eau. Mais il est
pas disponible sous forme
d'énergie. Donc pour l'avoir
sous forme hydrogène pur, faut
le séparer des autres atomes
auxquels il est associé et en
particulier de l'atome
d'oxygène dans l'eau. Ou du
carbone dans le méthane. Et
donc l'hydrogène on sait très
bien en faire, ça consomme
plein d'énergie et en fait on
en fait avec euh, en
l'extrayant à la fois de l'eau
et du méthane, du gaz naturel,
en mélangeant les deux, donc on
met du méthane et de l'eau
ensemble et on chauffe très
fort. Et du coup l'ensemble des
deux se réarrange et vous
faites de l'hydrogène et du
CO2. Faire une tonne
d'hydrogène aujourd'hui c'est
dix tonnes de CO2 avec ce
processus Si vous le faites
avec la gazéification du
charbon, qui est également une
possibilité, trente tonnes de
CO2 par tonne d'hydrogène. Donc
pour que l'hydrogène devienne
un JANCOVICI dans une
décarbonation de l'économie, il
faut le produire sans émettre
de CO2. Alors je vais pas
rentrer dans les détails
techniques. Le truc qui est
parce qu'il y a plusieurs
manières de faire, mais la
manière que tout le monde a en
tête, c'est l'électrolyse de
l'eau. Mais à ce moment, il
faut que l'électricité de
départ soit décarbonnée. Parce
que si vous électronisez
l'hydrogène avec de
l'électricité faite au charbon
ou au gaz, et par exemple si
vous faites de l'hydrogène avec
le mix énergétique enfin le
mixte électrique pardon pas
énergétique le mix, électrique
allemand moyen actuel, votre
voiture à hydrogène elle vous
émet deux fois plus de CO2 que
votre voiture à essence. donc
il faut bien le faire
l'hydrogène, vous pouvez pas
mal le faire. On peut faire
comme hydrogène avec de
l'électrolyse? Alors je vais
vous donner euh un exemple. Si
vous voulez remplacer le
pétrole des transports de
marchandises en poids lourds en
France par de l'hydrogène, il
faut augmenter la production
française d'électricité de
vingt pour cent. Donc en gros,
il vous faut dix à douze
réacteurs nucléaires actuels de
plus. On peut le faire ça va
pas se faire comme ça. Hein
Pour les avions à hydrogène
c'est pareil euh c'est la même
quantité qu'il faudrait euh de
de réacteur en plus si on
voulait faire voler à
l'hydrogène les avions qui
quittent le sol français en ce
moment enfin avant covid bon
donc on pardon? faut faire avec
euh du covid surtout, c'est
plus efficace. Euh et si on
fait avec des éoliennes et du
solaire, c'est encore pire et
surtout c'est beaucoup plus
carboné euh puisque euh ça le
le panneau solaire il est à
cinquante grammes de CO2 par
kilowatt heure, donc le
kilowattheure d'hydrogène
derrière par électrolyse, il
est à cent grammes de CO2 euh
enfin en gros quand vous
regardez, vous vous rendez
compte que euh l'hydrogène, en
fait, il y a deux applications
où c'est intéressant, et pour
le reste, en particulier dans
les transports, ça JANCOVICI
les gens euh aux vélos
électriques euh que de et de
construire des pistes cyclables
euh que d'essayer de mettre
toutes les voitures à
hydrogène, c'est-à-dire
beaucoup plus vite! le
l'hydrogène, il y a deux
applications où ça peut être
intéressant, c'est pour faire
des engrais parce que même si
on aime l'agriculture douce et
cetera, ce qui est mon cas, on
va encore avoir besoin
d'engrais pendant un petit
moment. Euh et la chimie des
engrais démarre avec la
synthèse de l'ammoniac, et ça,
ça démarre avec la la
production d'hydrogène. C'est à
ça que sert quarante pour cent
de l'hydrogène produit dans le
monde. Et la deuxième chose qui
est intéressante avec de
l'hydrogène, c'est de faire de
l'acier sans CO2. Aujourd'hui
l'acier est fait en mélangeant
du minerai de fer, c'est-à-dire
un oxyde de fer avec du
charbon, très particulier, du
cha métallurgique et le charbon
vous enlève l'oxygène de
l'oxyde de fer et vous laisse
le faire. D'accord? C'est comme
ça que ça marche. Eh ben pour
enlever l'oxygène de oxyde de
fer, on peut aussi utiliser de
l'hydrogène. Les Suédois ont
mis quarante milliards sur la
table pour démarrer un projet
comme ça. Donc le deuxième truc
intéressant avec de à faire
avec de l'hydrogène décarboné
c'est de l'acier décarboné et
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
de l'acier il y en a absolument
partout dans nos vies, c'est
aussi indispensable que le
pétrole pour le mode que nous
avons euh aujourd'hui. Donc les
deux les deux applications
intéressantes de l'hydrogène
pour moi c'est des applications
JANCOVICI c'est l'acier et les
engrais. Donc on commence déjà
par s'occuper de ça. Et si
éventuellement il reste une
tonne d'hydrogène, on fera un
dirigeable, non je plaisante,
on fera un avion à hydrogène
mais euh c'est pas ça qui va
sauver le transport aérien.
Alors une dernière question sur
euh, la partie euh, production
d'énergie, il y a d'autres
questions qui sont venues
entre-temps mais on pourra
peut-être faire revenir dans
dans un second temps euh, la
biomasse. Et quelles est-ce
qu'on peut euh, lui accorder,
quelles sont ses possibilités
de croissance Alors, la
biomasse est une des manières
d'utiliser le sol Euh, en
passant aux JANCOVICI fossiles
euh, quelque chose de très
remarquable qui s'est produit
c'est qu'on a plus besoin de
l'espace énergétique puisque
tout venait du sous-sol. on
avait besoin du sol, on avait
besoin de l'herbe pour nourrir
les animaux de très, c'était de
l'énergie, euh et après on a
plus eu besoin de l'herbe pour
nourrir les animaux de trait et
parce que on avait besoin du
bois pour se chauffer et pour
alimenter les forges. Du reste,
on en avait tellement besoin
que la France était en pleine
JANCOVICI jusqu'en
dix-huit-cent-cinquante, c'est
le charbon qui a sauvé les
forêts françaises, aussi
étonnant que ça puisse
paraître. Et euh, une fois que
on a eu le charbon, ben on a
plus besoin des arbres euh,
donc euh, on les a laissé
pousser. Donc, le le le le sol.
Entièrement pour nos activités
alimentaires récréatives et les
infrastructures depuis qu'on a
les combustibles fossiles.
Quand on veut repasser aux
énergies renouvelables, on a de
nouveau besoin du sol. On a de
nouveaux besoins du sol,
notamment pour l'énergie qui va
les combustibles fossiles.
Alors c'est la biomasse hein
euh ou ça peut être de la
surface JANCOVICI solaires, peu
importe. Euh on a besoin euh du
sol pour le matériau. On veut
plus de plastique, on veut plus
d'acier, alors on va utiliser
du bois, pour ça il faut du
sol. On veut plus de plastique
pour s'habiller, on veut des
fibres textiles mais pour ça
euh, JANCOVICI donc en fait on
va se retrouver avec une
concurrence d'usage du sol et
enfin on a besoin du sol pour
les activités du pays,
c'est-à-dire laisser vivre les
petites bêtes, la biodiversité.
Donc en fait le sol il est
l'objet d'un nombre d'usages
euh concurrentiels entre
lesquels il faut arbitrer. Donc
la bonne question c'est
arbitrage ou est-ce qu'on met
la biomasse? Est-ce que on
laisse la forêt et faire un
puits de carbone et on se
chauffe au gaz? Ou est-ce que
on se chauffe au bois en
laissant pas la forêt pousser?
Eh bien la réponse à cette
question c'est que en fait on
peut utiliser au mieux ou plus
plus exactement le surplus qui
arrive dans une dans un
écosystème mature. Donc en gros
tant que l'écosystème est en
croissance, faut le laisser
pousser et une fois qu'il est
mature, on peut utiliser euh le
le la production supplémentaire
excédentaire de cet écosystème
qui sinon euh mourrait, se
décomposerait et cetera. Donc
quand vous regardez ce que ça
représente en France, euh ça
représente pas très loin dans
ce qu'on utilise déjà. Euh on
pourrait en utiliser
considérablement plus euh, et
donc le le la biomasse est une
bonne idée pour le chauffage en
en en milieu rural et le biogaz
dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
est aussi un usage pertinent de
la biomasse mais tout ça doit
se faire dans des limites qui
sont les limites euh, de la
non-atteinte à la capacité
enfin à la à la à la au stock
de biomasse que on a euh, dans
le pays parce que si on diminue
le stock de biomasse à ce
moment c'est de la
déforestation ça contribue aux
émissions Et alors juste pour
rebondir du coup sur cette
dernière euh question de sur la
la biomasse et sur notamment
sur le biogaz est-ce que le
biogaz n'a pas un risque de
concurrence avec l'agriculture
conventionnelle? Et euh enfin
l'agriculture tout court.
Est-ce qu'on n'a pas un risque
euh d'appauvrissement des sols
euh à long terme? Alors il y a
il y a il y a beaucoup de
questions là aussi là-dedans
qui sont bah mélange à la fois
les pratiques agricoles euh et
le produit des cultures. Donc
le produit des cultures je
viens de répondre si bien sûr
euh il y a un risque de
concurrence puisque encore une
fois le sol on peut pas
l'utiliser euh c'est c'est
c'est c'est comme l'histoire de
la de la crémière hein. On peut
pas l'utiliser pour euh
plusieurs choses à la fois.
Donc euh si on l'utilise pour
se nourrir, on l'utilise pas
pour la biomasse euh
énergétique si on l'utilise
pour euh faire des fibres
textiles on l'utilise pas pour
la biomasse énergétique
JANCOVICI et cetera. Donc on a
un arbitrage à faire entre tous
ces usages donc est-ce qu'il y
a pas un risque de concurrence
si il y a de fait un risque de
concurrence? Après est-ce que
les pratiques euh, est-ce que
euh, tel usage favorisent telle
dégradation du sol,
c'est-à-dire est-ce que le sol
se dégrade plus vite si on fait
des plantes énergétiques que si
on fait des plantes
alimentaires. Là la réponse est
non. Euh, c'est la pratique
agricole elle-même euh, qui
détermine ce qui va se passer
avec le sol Okay, il me semble
qu'on avait des questions aussi
sur les conséquences du
changement climatique, on
change un peu de thématique.
Voilà alors bon pour venir sur
notre thématique du coup je
pense que euh pas mal de
personnes ont réagi par rapport
à votre dernière dépositive.
Euh est-ce qu'on euh vous en
avez pas parlé mais euh quid de
l'emballement climatique de ce
qu'on appelle l'emballement
climatique? Alors ce qu'on
appelle l'emballement
climatique c'est la possibilité
qu'un certain nombre de
premières conséquences du
réchauffement climatique
contribuent à accélérer le
processus en relâchant plus de
gaz à effet de serre dans
l'atmosphère. Alors ces
JANCOVICI euh il y en a
plusieurs qui que je vais
décrire. Le premier c'est le
dépérissement des écosystèmes.
Par exemple si les forêts se
mettent à brûler de plus en
plus souvent, une forêt qui
brûle, c'est du CO2 qui repart
dans l'air. Et par ailleurs,
c'est un écosystème affaibli
derrière pour repomper du CO2
en provenance de l'atmosphère.
Hein, ça c'est un phénomène
d'emballement. Un deuxième
phénomène d'emballement, alors
plus local, celui-ci, c'est la
fonte de la banquise. Quand la
banquise fond, vous avez euh
une surface très
réfléchissante, la glace qui
est remplacée par une JANCOVICI
très absorbante qui est l'eau
océanique et à ce moment
l'océan se met à se réchauffer
plus vite puisqu'il absorbe
plus d'énergie du soleil Autre
exemple d'emballement, vous
avez euh dans les régions du
nord, enfin plus exactement
près des pôles, mais c'est
surtout les régions du nord euh
près du pôle nord, puisque au
sud c'est très océanique. Enfin
le pôle sud est très océanique.
Euh vous avez du sol gelé en
permanence, qu'on appelle du
pergélisol ou du permafrost,
dans lequel vous avez du
carbone qui est contenu. Ce
carbone peut être contenu sous
forme de carbo pure soit sous
forme de méthane. Et quand le
sol dégèle, ce qui lui était
pas arrivé depuis des millions
d'années, eh bien à ce moment
il relâche le carbone qu'il
contient et ça ça fait une
source additionnelle euh
d'émission de gaz à effet de
serre dans l'atmosphère. Voilà
des phénomènes d'emballement.
Alors la mauvaise nouvelle euh
c'est que la science, comme on
est en train de faire une
expérience pour la première
fois, la science connaît mal
les seuils qui s'appliquent à
tous ces phénomènes. On les
connaît pas euh tous autant que
vous êtes, vous avez fait des
expériences pour la première
fois dans votre par exemple
vous mariez euh, qui dans cette
salle s'étant marié a eu très
exactement sur les vingt ans
qui ont suivi ce qu'il
s'imaginait qu'il ou elle
aurait. Bon, à peu près
personne. Donc, quand vous
faites une expérience pour la
première fois, vous avez
toujours des surprises. Ça fait
partie de la règle du jeu.
Donc, en ce qui concerne ces
phénomènes d'emballement, on
aura nécessairement des
surprises bonnes ou mauvaises,
pour le moment, on en a plutôt
des mauvaises. C'est-à-dire que
quand vous regardez la
production scientifique de ces
dernières années, pour à peu
près tous les phénomènes qui
sont regardés d'un peu près,
les conséquences ont ça va
aller plus vite et à se
rapprocher plus vite que l'idée
qu'on s'en faisait il y a
quelques années et donc la la
la question sous-jacente
évidemment que à un moment le
truc échappe à tout contrôle
euh, et que quoi qu'on fasse de
toute façon euh, et bien on va
vers euh, une le l'état l'état
guerrier euh, dont je parlais
tout à l'heure euh, et
évidemment un peu désagréable
la science aujourd'hui n'a pas
la réponse, c'est-à-dire que il
y a un certain nombre de
conséquences qui sont
qualitativement JANCOVICI mais
les seuils précis bah, euh,
difficiles. Je vais vous donner
un exemple euh, au dernier
dernier rapport du GIEC parlait
d'une JANCOVICI au niveau du
niveau de la mer à l'horizon de
quelques siècles qui était de
deux ou trois mètres. Dans le
prochain rapport du siècle,
dans le scénario, c'est monté à
seize. et la raison, c'est
l'accélération de la faune du
Groenland et les craintes sur
la désintégration de
l'Antarctique de l'Ouest,
JANCOVICI sont apparues dans la
littérature scientifique ces
dernières années. Et donc
évidemment la presse grand
public vous parle quand ils ont
fini de vous parler de la
composition de l'équipe de
France. Donc le qui est aussi
un sujet important mais euh
donc le le voilà donc ces
processus normalement euh j'ai
envie de dire malheureusement
on en découvre un peu tous les
jours. Euh parce que difficile
euh, à évaluer euh, longtemps à
l'avance. Mais il y en aura.
euh, alors vous l'avez je pense
que vous l'avez JANCOVICI mais
vous avez euh, rebondir dessus
je pense assez facilement,
c'est euh, quelles sont les
conséquences du réchauffement
sur la ressource en eau et la
disponibilité en eau? Alors,
sur la ressource en eau, le
réchauffement climatique en en
va globalement conduire à un
assèchement des sols. Qu'est-ce
qui se passe dans le cadre d'un
climat qui se réchauffe? Vous
avez plusieurs choses qui se
mettent à passer en
simultanément. La première
c'est qu'un climat plus chaud
favorise l'évaporation partout
où il y a de l'eau et en
particulier au-dessus des
océans. Donc, un climat plus
chaud favorise l'évaporation en
provenance des océans. Donc il
va y avoir plus de
précipitation parce que une
fois que la vapeur d'eau est
rentrée dans l'atmosphère, elle
condense et elle pleut, enfin
voilà bon. Et la question c'est
euh, est-ce que ça va pleuvoir
partout de la même manière ou
pas? Et là, la réponse est non.
Et en particulier tout le
pourtour du bassin
méditerranéen, et la France est
un tout petit peu concernée,
euh, va avoir plutôt un déficit
de précipitation euh,
c'est-à-dire que le surplus de
pluie ça concernera les autres
euh, mais pas nous. Ensuite, la
pluie peut très bien être plus
abondante dans l'année, mais
plus mal répartie. Vous vous
rappelez de l' épisodes de
précipitations intenses qui a
eu lieu dans le sud de la
France il y a pas très
longtemps euh, là où les
inondations ont eu lieu, ils
ont pris localement huit-cents
millimètres de pluie en euh,
vingt-quatre ou quarante-huit
heures, huit-cent millimètres
c'est les précipitations
annuelles normales ici
d'accord? En vingt-quatre
heures. Donc vous avez un
épisode et demi comme ça dans
l'année et puis plus rien le
reste de l'année vous voyez
vous avez plus de
précipitations que d'habitude
mais enfin ça fait pas vraiment
vos affaires. Et en fait ce qui
compte vraiment en ce qui
concerne la facilité qu'ont les
plantes à pousser c'est certes
ce qu'il pleut mais surtout ce
que le sol va en garder. Donc
en fait ce qui compte
l'humilité des sols. Et ce qui
est vraiment intéressant pour
savoir si demain l'agriculture
et les écosystèmes se porteront
bien c'est est-ce que les sols
vont être globalement plus secs
ou globalement plus humides? Et
là en France la réponse c'est
qu'ils vont devenir globalement
plus secs. Même si il pleut un
peu plus, l'évaporation des
sols va aussi fortement
augmenter Et il suffit que ces
précipitations soient plus mal
réparties, ce qui est aussi une
tendance à venir dans le cadre
du réchauffement JANCOVICI que
je devrais plutôt appeler la
dérive climatique pour que du
coup les sols s'assèchent. Donc
euh la la la à pardon, le la
sécheresse euh, agricole euh,
et la sécheresse des sols euh,
vont statistiquement augmenter
à l'avenir euh, en France
D'accord, alors une dernière
question sur ces conséquences,
on on parle aussi notamment du
et du ralentissement du Google
Stream courant qui est censé
nous apporter de la chaleur.
euh, comment est-ce que ça
intervient dans tout ça? Alors
le Gallstream, en fait c'est
une expression qui est un peu
impropre euh, le vrai
Gallstream il désigne euh, un
courant qui comme son nom
l'indique est dans le golf Golf
Stream le courant du golf donc
en fait le Golf Stream c'est
une boucle qui ne quitte pas
l'Équateur, ce qui nous
réchauffe en Europe ça
s'appelle la dérive
nord-Atlantique euh, et c'est
un embranchement du Gallstream
qui remonte et qui va jusqu'au
sud du Gros Élan où là l'eau se
met à plonger. Euh alors les
raisons pour lesquelles ça se
passe comme ça euh je vais pas
les détailler ce soir sinon je
vais vous JANCOVICI euh par
contre euh ce qui est important
c'est que le le moteur de cette
dérive nord-atlantique c'est
notamment la plongée des
JANCOVICI au sud du Grosland
qui sert de pompe aspirante les
JANCOVICI ça vous aspire euh
l'eau qui est à côté. Alors la
raison pour laquelle les
JANCOVICI c'est à cause de leur
température, de la formation de
la banquise, de leur densité
euh et cetera. Bon bref Dans un
qui se réchauffe, un des trucs
qui pourrait se passer c'est
une augmentation des
précipitations sur l'océan
lui-même et à ce moment un
adoucissement euh, de l'eau, la
salinité diminue et à ce moment
la densité de l'eau diminue et
elle plonge moins facilement.
Et vous avez également un effet
qui est dû au moins à la
moindre formation de la
banquise. Et alors si la
plongée des JANCOVICI se
ralentit, à ce moment la dérive
Nord-Atlantique se ralentit. Et
en fait, il y a eu des époques
dans le passé où cette plongée
des JANCOVICI interrompue, elle
a un mode on off hein euh un
interrupteur et à ce moment
euh, vous avez une modification
drastique du climat régional en
Europe euh, qui s'opère en
quelques décennies. Alors, si
ce processus JANCOVICI à
l'avenir, dans un contexte de
réchauffement global, euh, là
pour le coup, les modélisateurs
sont euh, ont pas de goût,
enfin beaucoup vous disent, la
température en Europe, c'était
en moyenne euh, pour autant
euh, n'évoluera pas à la
baisse, par rapport à
aujourd'hui. Euh, d'aucuns vous
disent mais on se rapprochera
d'un climat continental euh,
donc en fait avec des des
contrastes entre les saisons
beaucoup plus marquées. Euh, et
c'est en fait peut-être que ça
sera beaucoup plus sec enfin
c'est un peu la bouteille à
l'encre euh, en fait on sait
pas trop euh, ce qui se passe
si jamais euh, cette dérive
nord-atlantique s'interrompt à
l'avenir. Pour le moment il est
pas prévu qu'elle s'interrompe
dans le siècle à venir mais à
l'échelle de quelques siècles
un point d'interrogation
supplémentaire Okay, alors on a
dressé un certain nombre de
constats ce soir, tiré un
certain nombre euh d'alerte au
niveau mondial, national. Une
des questions à mon avis qui
arrive souvent aussi, c'est
comment on passe à l'action
locale, comment on peut être un
territoire euh bas carbone, par
où il faut commencer. Alors il
faut commencer par mesurer. Euh
un des problèmes que vous allez
avoir, c'est que euh la
décentralisation du pouvoir
n'est pas allée avec la
décentralisation de
l'expertise. Euh et donc euh un
des une des difficultés euh,
qu'il y a dans la gestion
locale, c'est d'arriver à avoir
toute l'information qui va du
global au local euh, pour
savoir où est-ce qu'on a des
marges de manre et où est-ce
qu'on est dans la barque
commune et en fait euh, on on
peut revendiquer des mais en
fait ça ça restera des slogans
euh, parce que on n'a pas les
on n'a pas les leviers de
l'action. Euh Un point
important de mon point de vue,
c'est qu'il faut pas opposer
euh le local et le national euh
parce que si on décide de
commencer à dire c'est à toi, à
moi, et cetera euh on va pas
s'en sortir, donc il faut qu'on
essaye de ramer tous dans le
même sens
le
ce qui est à la main du du
local on va dire, dans
l'ensemble de ce qu'il faut
faire. Alors je vais commencer
par dire ce qu'il faut faire.
Euh si on veut être sérieux sur
la question climatique, il faut
qu'on agisse sur les émissions
qui sont associées à notre mode
de vie. Vous avez, c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'empreinte
carbone. Vous avez quatre gros
paquets dans ces émissions.
Vous avez ce qu'on mange, vous
avez ce qu'on achète, vous avez
là où on vit, donc les
émissions associées au logement
et vous avez la façon de se
déplacer. Voilà, en gros, les
quatre gros paquets. Et vous
avez un cinquième Paquet qui
sont les services publics qui
dépendent voilà si vous êtes
malade et que vous allez à
l'hôpital et euh, si vous avez
des enfants qui vont à l'école
et cetera, c'est des émissions
dont vous bénéficiez aussi
hein, parce que les écoles faut
les construire, les chauffer,
l'hôpital faut le construire,
le chauffer, fabriquer les
médicaments, les scanners et
faire venir les infirmières.
Donc tout ça fait que euh, ça
fait des émissions. sur
l'alimentation le premier
déterminant de l'empreinte
carbone c'est la part de viande
qu'on mange et en particulier
viande rouge Donc là-dedans bah
il faut voir ce qui peut
revenir au local. Euh un truc
qui peut être pertinent, c'est
d'essayer de se mettre d'accord
entre acteurs locaux pour avoir
des pratiques d'élevage qui
conduisent à faire moins
d'animaux de meilleure qualité,
acheter plus cher. Faut pas que
l'éleveur se suicide. Euh et
euh valoriser ça au travers de
circuits plus courts euh en
sorte que les marges de
distribution sont moins élevées
euh et du coup les autres
acteurs de la chaîne s'y
retrouvent. Ah évidemment le
distributeur y perd. Tout le
monde peut pas gagner dans
cette histoire
mais en gros l'équation vous
l'avez là. Euh en ce qui
concerne la JANCOVICI alors ça
c'est pas du tout à la main du
territoire, c'est pas vous qui
allez demain matin fabriquer
vos chaussures euh votre robe
euh le micro que vous tenez à
la main, euh la voiture dans
laquelle vous êtes venue ici,
et c'est pas bien? Non, pardon.
Euh je suis venu en vélo. Je
sais pas. JANCOVICI du reste.
Euh voilà. Donc euh même si
c'est beaucoup mieux. Donc euh
le le territoire là-dessus,
qu'est-ce qu'il a comme mains,
j'ai envie de dire, euh il peut
avoir de euh, le remplacement
sur son sol, d'activité de
l'ancien monde entre guillemets
par des activités du nouveau
monde, donc si vous avez un
fabricant de portières de
voiture et que vous arrivez à
le convaincre de faire des
dérailleurs de vélo euh, c'est
pas, c'est pas plus mal. mais
mais sinon euh, c'est
essentiellement inciter euh,
les gens à essayer d'avoir
moins envie de trucs et de
machins pour passer le temps.
Hein bon. Il y a évidemment
quelque chose qui alors là euh,
est est dans la main des élus
qui est la question des locaux
euh, dédiés aux commerces tout
petit sujet mais l'action elle
se passe là aussi En ce qui
concerne le troisième point qui
est euh le logement Euh, là
peut faire le territoire, c'est
favoriser l'amélioration de
leur performance JANCOVICI et
en fait carboniques hein. Et
donc ça ça peut concerner à la
fois la montée en compétences
des filières professionnelles
parce que c'est un énorme sujet
euh, la montée en compétences
des filières professionnelles,
ça peut concerner euh, de
l'artisanat de fabrication euh,
de matériaux, d'appareils de
chauffage euh, et cetera. et
évidemment euh, des habitants
du territoire euh, à améliorer
la performance carbonique de
leur logement Et c'est vrai
également pour le tertiaire.
Euh, et enfin euh, en ce qui
concerne le quatrième morceau
qui est se déplacer euh, là
c'est pareil, le territoire
c'est pas lui qui va fabriquer
les véhicules, par contre il
peut inciter euh, à des
JANCOVICI différenciés donc il
peut s'occuper euh, des
transports en commun il peut
s'occuper des infrastructures
pour le vélo euh, et il peut
s'occupe et il y a et moi mon
JANCOVICI c'est que il y a
quelque chose qui est en train
de beaucoup changer la pratique
dans le vélo qui est JANCOVICI
parce que l'électrification
fait que il y a plein de gens
qui ont pas peur de monter sur
un vélo euh, même s'ils ont pas
fait de sport depuis
quarante-cinq ans et demi. Euh,
alors qu'avec le vélo mécanique
euh, il y a cette il y a cette
peur euh, et par ailleurs il y
a un vrai un vrai sujet sur le
vélo qui est la non
cohabitation avec d'autres
JANCOVICI qui sont dangereux
pour lui
c'est les voitures mais il y en
a aussi un autre qui est ceux
qui sont plus légers et moins
rapides qui sont les piétons.
Euh les voies mixtes cyclistes
piétons euh, c'est très
dangereux euh, parce que le
piéton pense qu'il est chez
lui, donc il fait pas gaffe à
la où il va euh, et il circule
en regardant son smartphone et
en laissant ses gosses euh,
jouer Euh, le cycliste pense
qu'il est chez lui euh, et il
dit je vais quand même pas
aller à la vitesse d'un piéton
sinon ça sert à rien que j'ai
un vélo euh, voilà et donc
c'est des c'est des endroits
qui sont euh, pas si rassurants
que ça euh, évidemment l'autre
c'est la c'est la c'est la
voiture. Euh et donc là le le
territoire peut agir aussi euh,
sur les infrastructures euh, et
puisque un des partenaires
préférés du territoire c'est le
BTP euh, on peut très bien leur
demander de faire des pistes
cyclables euh, plutôt que de
faire des ronds-points. Donc
euh, des pistes vélo travail
des pistes du quotidien. Ah oui
oui, des pistes du quotidien,
oui oui, bien Maintenant, quand
il y aura moins de touristes
japonais venant en avion, ça
sera pas mal aussi d'avoir des
pistes cycles à longue distance
pour faire venir les Parisiens
en vélo. Euh et euh, leur
offrir le gîte et le couvert
une fois qu'ils sont arrivés
jusque chez vous. Euh, eh
ah ben oui oui oui ben ça
reviendra pour ça voilà donc
voilà en gros ce territoire à
la main, sur quoi il a pas la
main, il a pas la main sur la
production des voitures et
encore moins sur leur
normalisation, il a la main sur
les obligations réglementaires
qui sont du ressort de l'État,
il a pas la main sur la
fiscalité, il a pas voilà donc
il faut à la fois qui s'empare
de ce sur quoi il peut avoir la
main euh sans attendre que les
autres euh le fassent. Et et ne
pas tenir un discours qui à mon
avis est contre-productif, qui
est de dire euh il y a que chez
moi qui se passe des choses
l'Etat quand même qu'elle ils
ont rien compris même si c'est
vrai parfois mais euh et euh,
essayer de convaincre justement
euh, aux sphères euh, dans dans
la sphère nationale euh, que il
faut que tout ça se fasse de
manière coordonnée. Je je
retiens hein, la dimension euh,
formation hein, donc ce soir on
est euh, tous en formation euh,
en direct. Je retiens
l'alimentation et le pays euh,
porte un projet alimentaire
territorial, j'en profite parce
que Noël Tellier est notre élu
référent est présent ce soir
euh, et le pays porte aussi une
plateforme territoriale de
rénovation énergétique qui
souhaite euh, accompagner tous
les habitants du territoire
dans la rénovation de leur
logement. Donc voilà, c'est
c'est pas parfait mais on on
fait notre part. Une nouvelle
question peut-être euh,
Olivier? Euh, oui bon on a un
public qui est majoritairement
composé d'élus euh, donc il y a
plusieurs questions qui
reviennent hein, sur euh, cet
aspect vraiment très concret.
Euh, est-ce que vous avez
d'autres exemples que d'actions
que les élus peuvent mettre en
place, notamment les élus des
petites communes? Je redis, je
pense que il y a quelque chose
d'absolument essentiel qui est
de commencer par euh,
comprendre euh, alors
aujourd'hui il y a des il y a
des outils euh, qui qui aident
à comprendre et euh, je je vais
reparler de l'expérience, enfin
il y a deux trucs qui me
paraissent importants, je vais
reparler de l'expérience à
laquelle a participé Mélanie
qui est la Conventionne pour le
climat qui me semble avoir
montré l'effet de levier dû à
deux éléments qui sont
essentiels, qui sont la
formation et le fait de d'agir
de manière concertée. Euh, donc
de parler en haut. Euh et le
donc dans les petites communes
il me semble que c'est les deux
premières marches de l'escalier
quoi qu'on fasse derrière. Donc
ce qu'il faut essayer de faire
c'est d'attirer l'intérêt d'une
partie aussi importante que
possible de la population sur
ces sujets-là. Euh je juste
leur dire euh on va essayer de
comprendre de quoi il se passe,
de quoi de quoi il retourne Et
donc il me semble que la la
bonne manière de commencer,
surtout dans les petites
communes où tout le monde se
connaît. C'est ça l'avantage
des types communes, c'est que
en gros euh c'est euh quelques
salles de classe euh ou ou un
lycée. Euh donc c'est pas très
c'est pas très compliqué de de
d'avoir tout le monde qui se
euh et la bonne manière de
créer de la confiance euh ou ou
de ou de ou de travailler avec
des gens qu'on connaît déjà euh
c'est de partir de la
définition du problème. Donc je
pense que dans les petites
communes c'est vraiment le
premier truc à faire avant de
savoir si on va faire euh un
jardin partagé, un potager je
sais pas euh c'est vraiment de
partir d'un d'un d'un constat
commun. Donc là il y a des
outils qui existent aujourd'hui
pour ça, par exemple il y a un
un jeu qui s'appelle la fresque
du climat euh, qui est un truc
euh, très low-tech hein euh, ça
se joue avec une grande feuille
de papier et un jeu de treize
cartes vraiment euh, trucs euh,
pas pas compliqué du tout euh,
eh bien même dans une petite
commune on peut faire ça euh,
et on apprend soi-même sur une
session ça dure quelques heures
euh, c'est un jeu collectif,
les gens jouent par équipe, ils
ne s'opposent pas euh, c'est
important euh, ça permet de
commencer à toucher un peu du
doigt le sujet que j'ai évoqué
ce soir euh, il y a des outils
également pour découvrir ce que
c'est que son JANCOVICI carbone
personnelle euh, aujourd'hui
Carbone quatre a mis au place a
mis au point par exemple un
outil qui s'appelle My Cot
alors je suis désolé c'est en
JANCOVICI mais bon vous
comprendrez tous mon CO2. Euh,
et euh, c'est un outil qui se
déploie notamment par le biais
d'ambassadeurs euh, donc des
gens qui peuvent faire des
conférences en en rétribuant
une somme tout à fait
symbolique euh, et c'est
également quelque chose qui
peut prendre place euh, dans
une petite commune donc euh, un
un un diptyque par lequel
n'importe quelle petite commune
peut commencer, c'est une
fresque du climat et derrière
euh, cette conférence euh, sur
l'empreinte carbone JANCOVICI
et une fois qu'on a fait ça,
mon expérience c'est que les
gens auront des idées
Vous venez de répondre à une
autre question, donc c'est
c'est formidable. Du coup, mais
du coup je suis perdu. Euh,
donc du coup euh, la suivante
c'est euh, alors c'est une
question aussi hein, que se
posent nos élus, c'est comment
euh, agir et euh, notamment
dans la sobriété euh, comment
JANCOVICI ces actions-là tout
en restant attractifs et garder
un territoire attractif. Je
vais refaire la même réponse
euh, élu et vous le savez mieux
que moi, ça ne peut pas se
faire euh, en opposition
frontale avec vos électeurs
euh, donc ça dire que la
première chose à faire c'est de
leur donner envie d'aller dans
cette direction. Et la
meilleure manière que je
connaisse de leur donner envie,
c'est de leur JANCOVICI la
situation. J'en connais pas
d'autres. Euh donc je renvoie à
ce que j'ai dit juste avant, il
faut qu'il commence par euh
découvrir euh et ensuite ils
auront euh les idées viendront
toutes seules.
la commune en l'occurrence
des gens qui ont appelé euh, à
la mairie ils sont intéressés
pour euh, venir habiter à
Saouvigné et quand ils
apprennent j'ai participé à la
convention ça les conforte dans
l'idée de venir. Donc c'est pas
euh, rébarbatif de de de
vouloir réduire l'empreinte
carbone enfin. Non non. Il y a
plein de gens aujourd'hui,
c'est c'est ce qu'ils cherchent
quoi et et on on parlait à
Sablé qui a une perte euh, de
de certains nids de certaines
familles, les les les familles
euh, trente-cinq ans euh,
diplômées c'est ce qu'ils
recherchent en fait si euh il y
a il y a enfin bas carbone. Il
y a un organisme qui s'appelle
euh l'IRSN. Alors c'est c'est
l'institut, je crois ça doit
dire l'institut sur les risques
et la sûreté nucléaire. Quel
rapport avec ce qui va suivre?
Vous allez voir. Qui sort
chaque année un baromètre qui
vient de sortir là cette année
où ils essayent de comparer les
perceptions des Français sur un
certain nombre de problèmes
d'environnement. Et euh depuis
quelques années euh la question
du réchauffement climatique est
en train de monter en flèche
euh dans les préoccupations des
donc ça c'est un sondage qui a
été fait en novembre dernier
donc en plein covid hein qui
qui le dit et ça pas à ce
moment-là euh que je ne dise
pas euh de bêtises euh devant
le chômage alors qu'on était en
plein covid et donc les gens
savent très bien qu'il va y
avoir euh une douloureuse
économique derrière hein euh
devant le il y a il y a que le
terrorisme et la santé qui
étaient devant. Mais euh voilà
sinon euh les questions
d'environnement montent et au
sein des questions
d'environnement le
réchauffement climatique se
détache très nettement euh
devant les autres euh
aujourd'hui. Donc mon sentiment
c'est que de parler de ce de
sujet fait fuir de moins en
moins de monde et à l'inverse
euh, dire aux gens je vais on
va comprendre ensemble euh, est
une démarche qui peut être de
mieux en mieux perçue euh, par
une fraction croissante de la
population, en tout cas je
pense que ça vaut le coup
d'essayer.
Alors deux exemples de d'action
donc euh je vais vous donner
les deux en même temps. Les
zones à faible émission. Est-ce
que c'est efficace? Alors même
si c'est une zone à faible
émission? Ouais. Même si c'est
euh plus dédié à des
territoires urbains et la
deuxième question dans la
foulée, c'est est-ce que
l'agriculture peut être un bon
JANCOVICI pour le stockage euh
carbone? Alors les zones à
faible émission, sauf ailleurs
de ma part, c'est des endroits
où on essaye d'avoir des
transports qui sont euh on on
limite les émissions des des
véhicules, c'est ça hein euh
certaines caractéristiques
seulement et notamment dans les
grandes villes qui sont très
euh engorgées aux heures de
pointe. Alors ouais alors en
fait dans les pour JANCOVICI
les problèmes de transport la
bonne question à se poser c'est
pourquoi les gens se déplacent
il faut partir de là en général
euh, il y a deux il y a deux
JANCOVICI très différents il y
a la mobilité longue distance
qui est essentiellement une
mobilité de loisir et euh, il y
a la mobilité du quotidien qui
est essentiellement une
mobilité une mobilité qu'on
appelle contrainte euh,
c'est-à-dire que on part de son
domicile, on va au travail
faire les courses euh, aller
chercher les gosses à l'école
euh, et cetera bon
essentiellement ça. Et là dans
le domicile travail fait la
moitié hein. Alors les zones à
faible émission euh si il faut
donner une alternative,
c'est-à-dire quà partir du
moment où on dit dans cette
zone-là, il y aura plus tel et
tel type de véhicule, il faut
qu'on donne une alternative.
Alors ça dépend de quoi il
retourne. Si c'est des
camionnettes de livraison et
que l'alternative c'est que les
camionnettes de livraison
passent à l'électricité, bah ça
pose pas de problème. Si euh
ces zones-là, c'est des zones
euh qui sont des zones de
destination pour des gens
viennent en voiture bah, il
faut qu'ils puissent venir
autrement ou qu'on leur propose
de bosser de chez eux ou je
sais pas quoi, Mais en gros euh
parce qu'au moment où on met en
oeuvre euh la zone c'est pas
comme d'imposer quelque chose
sur le renouvellement des
voitures qui conduiraient à ce
que progressivement le parc de
voitures soit de plus en plus
compatible avec ce qu'on
cherche à faire. Là c'est
vraiment un truc euh du jour au
lendemain euh vous vous aviez
un véhicule qui est celui que
vous avez, vous aviez un une
destination qui était celle que
vous aviez on vous dit hop
c'est terminé Euh, ça va
beaucoup dépendre euh, de la
zone et du type de véhicule
qu'on veut sortir. Encore une
fois, et de la vitesse à
laquelle on fait. Je je je
pense que ça peut être euh, une
brique parmi beaucoup euh, il
faut regarder les mesures
concurrentes qui sont euh,
éventuellement qui permettent
d'arriver au même résultat euh,
il y a des il y a des il y a
des mesures qui peuvent être
euh, encore une fois arrivées
au même résultat et sans sans
dire leur nom. Euh, et sans
JANCOVICI pardon. Sans sans
sans s'appeler de la même
manière. Sans s'appeler de la
même manière. Sur la partie,
alors si je finis là-dessus
euh, pour vous donner un grand
huh ce sur quoi on a réfléchi
aux chiffres projects sur ce
qu'on a appelé les zones de
moyenne de densité euh, le le
cocktail qui permet d'avancer
sur la voie de la
décarbonation, mélange la
baisse des émissions unitaires,
des voitures toujours en
circulation, donc ça veut dire
qu'elles consomment moins si
elles restent au pétrole,
qu'elles passent à
l'électricité. Le covoiturage
L'augmentation des transports
en commun, essentiellement des
bus, parce que euh dans les
territoires de moyenne de
densité, on fait du bus, on
fait pas du train. Euh le vélo
et ces infrastructures dédiées,
et enfin ce qu'on a coutume
d'appeler la démobilité, alors
tous ceux d'entre vous qui sont
restés claquemurés pendant le
covid, se disent la démobilité,
ça va bien. Euh c'est clair que
la démobilité c'est pas, je
bouge plus du tout, c'est au
lieu de prendre ma voiture pour
aller au travail, je travaille
de chez moi mais je me prends
deux heures pour aller faire un
tour à pied. Voilà donc c'est
parce que sinon on explose.
Donc c'est c'est ça mais c'est
une forme de démobilité euh au
sens euh mécanique. Voilà en
gros le cocktail euh qui permet
de d'avancer et enfin le
dernier point qu'il faut garder
en tête c'est que les
marchandises n'ayant pas de
jambes. Le dernier transport
mécanique devront rester pour
les marchandises. Au moment où
euh le pétrole est arrivé dans
les pays qui en ont bénéficié,
ça a d'abord été utilisé pour
du transport de marchandises.
Il y a d'abord eu des camions
avant d'avoir des voitures. et
Mélanie parlait tout à l'heure
des gens qui venaient à vélo se
nourrir pendant la guerre euh,
dans la Sarthe euh, en fait il
est évident que demain matin
s'il y avait plus de camions en
France les grandes villes
meurent toutes de faim hein,
les grandes villes meurent
toutes de faim. Donc euh, vous
avez un un aujourd'hui un une
dépendance au pétrole dans le
transport de marchandises qui
est encore plus élevée dans le
transport de personnes parce
que tous les gens dans cette
salle qui font vingt kilomètres
dans la journée, si demain
matin il y a plus de voitures,
vous achetez un vélo
électrique, vous ronchonnerez
un peu mais vos vingt
kilomètres vous les ferez quand
même parce que vous avez des
jambes. Et que les marchandises
ça marche pas. Donc il faut
prendre sa rencontre dans
l'équation euh, qui est que la
mécanisation devra à l'avenir
rester JANCOVICI euh, allouée
aux marchandises euh, et pas
aux et pas aux personnes. Après
il y avait une question sur
l'agriculture qui était ouais
est-ce que l'agriculture peut
aider à stocker du carbone?
Est-ce que l'agriculture peut
Alors la réponse est oui, elle
doit même le faire. Euh en fait
dans les puits de carbone,
c'est-à-dire la manière de
reprendre une partie du carbone
stockée dans l'atmosphère euh
vous en avez deux, vous avez
les écosystèmes forestiers,
enfin vous en avez deux qui
sont vraiment sympathiques,
c'est des écosystèmes
forestiers et l'agriculture,
enfin qui peuvent l'être.
L'océan c'est pas terrible
parce que quand l'océan reprend
du CO2, il s'assignifie. Donc à
chaque fois que l'océan vous
reprend du CO2 qu'on a mis dans
l'air, ça rend la vie un peu
plus difficile, aux coraux, aux
planctons euh et à tout un tas
de qui ont besoin de
synthétiser du calcaire Donc
euh il vaut beaucoup mieux que
le CO2 soit repris par des
plantes. Alors euh les plantes
c'est quoi encore une fois?
C'est les forêts et
l'agriculture. Alors dans
l'agriculture en fait c'est pas
la plante elle va reprendre le
carbone. Euh vous faites
pousser le blé euh le blé vous
allez le manger où des animaux
vont le manger. À ce moment euh
le carbone qui est contenu dans
le blé va repartir dans
l'atmosphère sous forme euh de
CO2 dû à votre respiration.
C'est comme ça que ça se passe
hein. Vous mangez le carbone et
le carbone ressort sous forme
de respiration. Toute petite
partie ressort dans des
matières pas très odorantes
mais enfin ou pas très un peu
mais l'essentiel repart dans
l'air euh via votre respiration
Donc le CO2 était dans l'air
passe dans le blé, passe dans
votre estomac, repart dans
l'air. Donc celui-là, il est à
cycle court, il contribue pas à
séquestrer quoi que ce soit.
Celui qui contribue à
séquestrer quelque chose, c'est
le carbone qui passe dans les
racines du blé et dont une
petite partie reste dans le sol
parce que vous allez arrêter de
la bourrer le sol. Voilà, c'est
ça euh, la séquestration du
carbone euh, par les sols
agricoles. Alors, ça peut se
faire de cette manière, ça peut
se faire en remettant des haies
dans les champs. À ce moment,
vous avez du carbone permanent
euh, dans la haie et dans les
racines des S, c'est ce qu'on
appelle agroforesterie. Euh
donc en gros les deux grandes
pratiques qui permettent de
remettre du carbone dans les
sols, c'est l'arrêt du labour,
parce que ça d'exposer le
l'humus, le carbone du sol à
l'oxygène de l'air euh et donc
de l'oxydé. Et euh de planter
des arbres partout où on peut
euh donc euh ou ou de euh en
bord de champ euh ou euh
ailleurs quoi. En gros, voilà.
Très bien. Et donc une dernière
question sur les actions euh
qui de la mise en commun des
biens. Vous pourriez peut-être
du coup nous expliquer ce
qu'est l'économie de la
fonctionnalité et ce que vous
en pensez. Alors la mise en
commun des biens euh elle n'est
pas nécessairement en tant que
tel euh garant d'une baisse des
émissions. Euh je vais vous
donner un exemple JANCOVICI
l'avion. Si les seuls à pouvoir
se déplacer en avion étaient
les gens qui ont un jet privé
il y aurait beaucoup moins de
kérosènes consommées dans le
monde qu'aujourd'hui, beaucoup
moins puisque personne n'aurait
les moyens de s'acheter un jet
privé, quelques rares
milliardaires. Le fait d'avoir
mis en commun les avions permet
à chaque personne dans cette
salle de se prendre un billet
d'avion. Et du coup, la
consommation de l'aérien est
beaucoup plus importante que si
on ne pouvait prendre l'avion
qu'avec son propre avion. Donc
l'économie de la
fonctionnalité, en tant que
telle, n'est pas garante que on
va utiliser moins de
ressources. pas garant. Par
contre, ce qui peut marcher,
c'est si on dit je mets une
réglementation obligeant à
consommer moins de ressources.
Alors à ce moment, il peut
apparaître des partages qui
n'existaient pas avant. Et je
vais vous donner un exemple qui
s'appelle la colocation. Quand
on est suffisamment riche pour
s'offrir chacun son
appartement, on a chacun sa
salle de bain et sa douche. Et
puis si on n'est pas assez
riche et qu'on est en
colocation, ben il y a qu'une
seule salle de bain pour tout
le monde. Là on a fait de
l'économie de la
fonctionnalité, au lieu d'avoir
quinze mètres carrés de salle
de bain pour soie, on a quinze
mètres carrés de salle de bain
pour trois ou pour quatre. Donc
euh mais ça ça vient d'une
contrainte externe. Là en
l'occurrence que les gens n'ont
pas dé euh qui est
l'augmentation du prix de
l'immobilier. Hein donc quand
il y a une contrainte que
l'économie de la fonctionnalité
puisse permettre de répondre à
la contrainte, ça oui. Par
contre dire juste parce qu'il y
a de l'économie, de la
fonctionnalité et la
consommation globale va
baisser, ça non.
une petite transition euh faire
un mauvais jeu de mots mais
c'est pas grave. Euh justement
pour mener cette transition,
quelle organisation il faut
dans nos territoires? Est-ce
que euh est-ce que est-ce qu'il
y a une gouvernance qui permet
à la fois que les gens
s'emparent du sujet, à la fois
que les bonnes décisions soient
prises euh est-ce que il faut
plus de coopération? Est-ce
qu'il faut qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez? Il faut plus de
compréhension. Euh je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il y a encore
beaucoup d'endroits dans
lesquels euh les gens ont du
mal à se comprendre. Et donc
j'en reviens à je disais tout à
l'heure, je vraiment les je je
vais pas commencer à faire le
Parisien débarquer ici qui va
vous expliquer comment vous
allez gérer vos affaires euh,
parce que je suis pas sûr de
passer la nuit tranquille si je
fais ça donc euh, par contre ce
dont je suis absolument
convaincu c'est que euh, on
avance bien que quand on se
comprend et euh, le partage de
la connaissance c'est la
meilleure manière de de de
encore une fois je renvoie à
l'expérience de la Convention
Citoyenne pour le climat qui
est très éclairante de ce point
de vue quoi, faut commencer par
partager de la connaissance.
Euh, après vous verre qui en
sortira et ça va beaucoup
dépendre euh de l'endroit où on
sera. Mais je pense vraiment
que c'est ça le c'est ça la
base. Et alors là pour le coup
les élus doivent donner le bon
exemple. Donc s'il y a du
partage, de l'information et de
la formation, ben ils doivent
s'y coller les premiers. Bon
JANCOVICI . Pas à bon entendeur
salut à euh c'est normal
Est-ce que tu veux une autre
question Olivier? Est-ce que on
va y arriver sans euh envisager
une décroissance démographique?
Ah Alors euh j'ai une un
JANCOVICI , facile pour cette
question qui JANCOVICI
démographique, on l'aura de
toute façon d'ici à quatre
milliards d'années, euh moment
où la planète sera bouffée par
le soleil. Donc euh voilà. La
bonne question est de savoir
dans quelles conditions euh
alors si je dis des choses un
peu plus désagréables, euh il
est évident que notre planète
euh fait invariablement
treize-mille kilomètres de
diamètre au cours du temps.
Elle faisait treize-mille
kilomètres de diamètre il y a
cinq-mille ans, elle fait
treize-mille kilomètres de
diamètre, il y a deux siècles,
ça fait treize-mille kilomètres
de diamètre et dans un siècle
elle fera toujours treize-mille
kilomètres de diamètre voilà
n'en déplaise à à monsieur
Musk. Donc euh plus on est
nombreux dessus moins il y a de
morceaux de planètes absolument
évidents. Euh donc il y ait un
petit sujet avec la taille de
la population et après c'est
pas une population mondiale, ça
a pas tellement de sens. Euh
après euh il y a des
populations rapportées euh à
des territoires, des endroits
euh peut faire des choses et
cetera. euh, est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui euh, la planète
prise dans son ensemble peut
durablement supporter
huit-milliards de personnes
voulant comme euh, une classe
moyenne JANCOVICI , la réponse
est non. marche pas et voilà du
coup qu'est-ce qui va se passer
à l'avenir? Bah, je ne sais
pas, soit il y aura toujours
huit milliards d'individus et
euh le niveau de consommation
va baisser rapidement euh, soit
le niveau de consommation
baissera moins vite et le
nombre d'individus baissera
plus vite. Euh, alors qu'est-ce
qui fait baisser les individus?
Ben euh il y a deux causes,
hein. Euh la maladie et la
famine La guerre, c'est pas
très rapide. La guerre ça
favorise les maladies et les
famines. Ça oui. Euh mais les
morts militaires strictes euh
c'est pas énorme en fait euh
quand vous regardez bien euh le
vous rappeler euh, cet exemple
fameux hein, qui est que la
grippe espagnole a plus tué que
la guerre de quatorze dix-huit.
Donc, et la presse noire a été
euh, le la maladie enfin la la
régulation la plus la plus
violente de l'histoire de
l'humanité, ça a tué la moitié
des gens euh, à ce moment-là
euh, je voilà. Et ça a été très
étonnamment le début de la
prospérité européenne, la peste
noire parce que à l'époque des
énergies renouvelables, il y
avait plein de moulinants les
moulins servaient à moudre la
farine et au moment où la peste
arrive, la moitié de la
population disparaît et donc un
moulin sur deux se retrouve
disponible pour faire autre
chose que de la farine. Et
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait à ce
des soufflets de forge, des
marteaux et cetera. Et en fait
la production a démarré au
Moyen-Age juste après et ça a
préparé l'avènement de la
renaissance. Donc en fait le le
voilà voilà un exemple euh peu
connu euh de de maladie euh qui
a euh libéré de l'espace pour
ceux qui restaient euh pour
leur permettre de devenir euh
entre guillemets plus opulents.
Donc est-ce que on va échapper
à une régulation démographique
euh d'ici à ce que comme disait
Kenz on soit tous morts, non.
Euh elle prendra alors ça j'en
sais **** Euh est-ce qu'il faut
la souhaiter? Je vais pas vous
dire oui. Euh je veux dire euh
je ne suis en faveur JANCOVICI
euh épandée euh JANCOVICI euh
par contre euh est-ce que on
court le risque à ne pas
baisser notre consommation
matérielle, de ne pas JANCOVICI
le risque d'avoir une
régulation non désirée? Là la
réponse est très clairement
oui. Il est quelle heure là?
Moins cinq. Alors une dernière
question euh si on prend vue
territoriale hein, le Pays
Vallée de la Sarthe notamment,
c'est une toute petite part des
émissions de gaz à effet de
serre de la France qui
elle-même est une petite part
des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre du monde hein, vous voyez
où je veux en venir. Ça sert à
quelque chose? Est-ce que
voilà, est-ce que euh, les
actions locales auront une
influence sur les émissions
globales? La réponse est euh,
De toute façon, il y a motif à
agir même sans ça à cause de ce
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure sur
la diminution des ressources
faut bien voir encore une fois
qu'on a deux deux deux facteurs
limitants possibles dans notre
système, c'est la diminution
des ressources ou
l'augmentation des problèmes
JANCOVICI mais il y a un
problème qui peut arriver
indépendamment de des problèmes
environnementaux c'est la
diminution des ressources. Donc
se mettre en ordre de bataille
pour des ressources qui de
toute façon vont baisser a du
sens quoi que fassent les
autres. Mieux si les autres se
foutent du problème, ça veut
dire qu'ils vont se goberger de
ressources eux aussi donc il y
en aura moins pour nous. Donc
en fait, plus les autres s'en
foutent, si on prend ça sous
l'angle des ressources, et plus
il faut qu'on se dépêche d'agir
pour se rendre indépendant des
ressources en question. C'est
un premier paradoxe. Deux, euh,
je ne crois pas euh, à la
théorie qui voudrait que quand
on fait des choses dans une
direction donnée, le reste de
l'humanité y est indifférent.
Euh, vous savez que le
mimétisme est quelque chose qui
est très puissant chez nous et
euh, du reste c'est même comme
ça qu'on élève nos enfants.
C'est-à-dire l'essentiel de
l'éducation d'un enfant
consiste à leur faire faire par
JANCOVICI ce que nous faisons
de nous-mêmes. Limitation c'est
à la base de tous les
phénomènes de mode Pourquoi
est-ce que il y a des des
marques et cetera tout juste
parce qu'on veut JANCOVICI les
gens qui ont déjà, enfin je
veux dire c'est le mimétisme
qui est à la base de ça. Donc
l'homme étant un animal
extrêmement euh profondément
animé par le mimétisme et la
femme je précise euh et bien
euh oui pardon eh bien euh
l'idée euh je ne souscris pas
du tout à l'idée que si on
commence à faire des trucs qui
flottent face à la JANCOVICI ,
tous les autres vont nous
regarder en disant ouais c'est
vachement sympa ton truc mais
je ferais jamais pareil et
l'expérience que c'est pas ça
qui se passe. Euh donc le le le
l'idée que euh un un territoire
pourrait faire des choses
pertinentes et n'avoir jamais
nulle part aucun suiveur dans
le monde, j'y crois pas.
Par contre, si les choses sont
pas pertinentes, les autres
ailleurs auront euh beau jeu de
se gratter la tête en disant
euh, est-ce qu'il faut faire la
même chose? Bah, si c'est
pertinent, il y aura des
suiveurs. Si je prends à
l'échelle des pays le le la
France a déjà fait un certain
nombre de choses toute seule
dans son coin qui ensuite sont
devenus euh, JANCOVICI par
exemple le système métrique
euh, par exemple la TVA TVA
d'impôts enfin bon bref euh, et
euh, il y a pas très longtemps
le bilan carbone je veux dire
euh, la norme mondiale sur la
manière de faire une JANCOVICI
carbone d'une organisation,
c'est venu de la France. Tu es
même venu de votre serviteur,
qui un jour a été tout seul.
Donc, l'idée que on fasse des
trucs JANCOVICI dans son coin
et qu'ensuite ça diffuse, en
fait c'est la norme quoi, c'est
toujours comme ça que ça se
passe. Donc agissons. Donc il
faut agir sans se gratter la
tête. Merci infiniment monsieur
JANCOVICI je vous propose euh
de terminer cette soirée. Je
vais laisser le président nous
dire euh petit mot de la fin.
il en faut un désinfecté.
J'étais négatif il y a trois
jours. Ben restez, restez avec
moi euh monsieur JANCOVICI ,
restez avec euh ben oui, quand
même, pour pour le Maud, pour
le mot de la conclusion. Euh un
mot de la conclusion très très
rapide, d'abord euh vous
remercier bien sûr euh de votre
euh intervention, et puis euh à
plusieurs fois, euh plusieurs
reprises, vous avez été
mauvaise nouvelle. Vous nous
avez dit ce soir, mais j'ai
envie de dire aussi bonne
nouvelle, bonne nouvelle,
puisqu'on a un territoire, et
vous l'avez compris, sur un
plan alimentaire territorial,
sur de la rénovation
énergétique, sur les euh ce que
vous nous disiez, ce que vous
pouvez faire des collectivités,
donc je crois que on est sur la
bonne voie, on agit et puis
l'autre chose que je retiens et
que euh premier escalier, le de
la la première marche de
l'escalier c'est euh, la
sensibilisation et c'est je
crois ce que ce que nous en
fait euh, ce soir et donc on
est on est sur bonne voie il y
a aussi des choses positives
voilà parce que je l'ai terminé
euh, cette euh, conférence et
puis euh, on voulait vous
remercier aussi avec euh, des
euh, des produits euh, des
produits locaux alors on a fait
alors on n'a pas fait un panier
gourmand, on a fait un sac euh,
un sac du Vallée de la Sarthe
alors euh, pour les euh, pour
les les spectateurs oui c'est
lourd donc on a mis du
JANCOVICI vous avez pas eu le
temps de le tout à l'heure donc
euh on espère euh pouvoir le le
faire et puis euh de produits
locaux euh et qui est euh qui
sont produits sur sur le
territoire euh de la Vallée de
la Sarthe, des rillettes. Bien
sûr nous sommes là il y a des
rillettes et puis aussi nous
sommes à Sablé, donc euh euh le
petit Sablé que vous avez euh
là en effet aussi, puis du miel
enfin tout ce qu'on a plein de
bonnes choses qui vous
rappelleront votre passage dans
notre dans nos territoires et
puis euh n'hésitez pas de vous
y arrêter parce que passer
c'est bien mais euh arrêter,
c'est bien. Je suis JANCOVICI .
Vous êtes à l'arrêt. Merci à
vous. Bonne fin de soirée.